foreign
all right thank you good morning ladies
and gentlemen next witness
good morning your honor um plaintiff
calls tara roberts
all right let's see if we can get her on
here
nice miss roberts can you hear me
can you hear me miss roberts
mr roberts
i can see her
excuse me
yeah you can bring him in
see if she's on mute or not
she's right there
can you hear me mr roberts
yes i can okay great can you raise your
right hand for me
do you swear firm tell the truth on a
penalty of law
yes i do okay thank you man
we can't see her on the big screen
um
uh
just do a split screen so we can start
please
all right go ahead and ask your question
go ahead
it's the best we're gonna do right now
okay um
good morning would you please state your
name for the record
charlie roberts
miss roberts how do you know johnny depp
i managed his island in the exuma keys
in the bahamas for the past 15 years
miss roberts where do you live
i live on i live on the island and i
have a home in nassau and in long island
bahamas which i tried to get to as
frequently as possible
can you please describe mr depp's
private island generally
um
my duties on the private island would be
to
maintain the
island the buildings the houses
logistics not included or limited to
provisioning fuel
gas groceries
just day-to-day operations staff
and
kind of like an estate just in the
middle of nowhere
okay
um your honor i would like to pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 49 which has
previously been submitted into evidence
okay
um and mr gibson if you could play this
in um your honor if you could publish
this to the jury
thank you we can take that down
miss roberts do you recognize what is
shown in that video
yes that's johnny's house on the island
okay thank you
um
mr gibson can you please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 348
and this hasn't been submitted to
evidence yet so let's first just play
that for miss roberts
miss roberts do you recognize what is
shown in that video
that's his house and and uh closet area
okay
um your honor i'd like to plaintiff
submit this into evidence
all right 348 in evidence do you wish to
have it published yes can we please
publish that to the jury
and mr gibson once it's published if we
could play that again
and miss roberts what is that doorway
with the beads um that was just shown in
that video
that's the entrance to the closet
okay thank you we can take that down in
his house
thank you
miss roberts i believe you mentioned
that you manage staff on the island how
many people work with you on the island
uh myself and and three others is uh
jason major goes by cj
stephen farrow and rico major
is this i believe the witness is not
being shown to the jury right now
on their screens
thank you
there you go thank
you miss roberts how are you compensated
for your work on the island
i receive a monthly salary
other than this monthly salary what
other sources of income do you have
um i get dividends and rental from
family properties and businesses that we
have
since you've been working for mr dapp
how often have you seen him
um on average uh two three times a year
sometimes it was longer um more visits
sometimes i didn't see him for a period
of time depending on what his schedule
was or what was happening on the island
and how would you describe your
interactions with mr deb
um the island was a very family
atmosphere uh dinners together he's very
social
funny humorous
very kind with all of us and very very
outgoing and enjoyed working with him
and for him
when you first started working on mr
depp's island who would come down to the
island
um at the beginning it was um vanessa
and the children objection relevance
right hold on a minute ma'am objection
relevance
uh it goes to um
just
miss robert's knowledge of who came down
to the island we need to move forward
next question okay
um
uh miss roberts um when
well mr roberts are you aware if mr duff
brought or how often did mr depp bring
guests with him to the island
um
he had uh
i guess he would bring amber and amber
with our friends and also i had on one
of the occasions i had paul bettany and
his wife and his children
here on one of the trips
and when did the bet knees come down to
the island
um sometime in the summer of july 2013
what happened when the bet knees came
down
it was a normal trip i just we had an
incident where i was asked to
have amber leave the island i scheduled
a flight for her to leave to go to
florida that morning and then that
afternoon i was told to
bring her back and i arranged for a
flight for her to come back that
afternoon to the island
when did you first meet miss heard
i believe it was shortly after they
started dating
what was your impression of misheard
when you first met her
objection oh they're very much in love
relevance
okay go ahead
next question
all right
go ahead i think miss bradhoff has drawn
her objection yes go ahead okay so uh
miss roberts you can answer what was
your first what was your impression of
miss heard when you first met her
oh they were very nice a couple in love
they she cooked for him
cleaned up they took care of each other
they were a very happy couple
when if at all did that change
and with each visit it changed um
more of um
it was more not
like an island life anymore it was more
of um
wines and and more more requests
simple things toiletries uh to have
things here in place before they came
where she came as well um so it you know
luggage changed we've got more and more
luggage we i mean just things evolved
and kind of mushroomed
mushroomed a bit
how often would you see miss heard on
the island when she was in a
relationship with mr deb
i would
on average every day i'm taking meals
cleaning houses
um
sometimes more
and how often would miss herd come down
to the island
um
the
at the beginning probably the same two
or three times a year um
sometimes three times with her friends
and family and
johnny
during your interactions with miss heard
what if any changes did you observe of
this herd
um the
the
taking care of the cooking the meals we
had we then had a chef come to cook um
it was more of um it was more of a
formal island um with chefs and
housekeepers and things like that
changed
and
yeah pretty much that
miss roberts were you on the island in
august 2014 for mr depp's detox
yes i was
who else was on the island
um i flew to nassau and met um
johnny
amber and dad
i brought them flew them back to the
island and then a couple
oh miss roberts i believe you froze
there for a second um i heard you say
johnny amber and deb and then you were
cut off for a second
a couple of days into a couple days
later dr kipper arrived
what do you recall about that time that
mr depp came down to the island in
august 2014
um that he he was going to be here
they were going to be here for extended
period of time at least a month or
longer
and so we provisioned for a month
for the trip
and after about a week or two
they left
where was mr depp staying for the detox
in in his house
is that the same house that was just
shown in those videos earlier
yes it was
how often would you see mr depp when he
was on the island for the detox
um
i was
every day but not um face to face um
just from delivering um some
replenishing the house delivering
supplies waters and things like that
linens and changing things out so
glimpsing him not not a conversation as
it used to be
how was mr depp when you saw him
uh he was always asleep on the couch
while miss heard was on the island for
the detox what if any injuries did you
observe on this herd
i didn't i didn't see anything
after mr dapp and miss heard left the
island what happened next
um we would go into the house and and
break it down
empty out the refrigerators change the
linens collect the laundry
straighten the house back up again
after they left um what if any property
damage did you observe
there wasn't any
okay
miss roberts to what extent were you
involved in mr depp and mrs heard's
wedding in february 2015 on the island
pretty much all aspects of it logistics
uh work permits getting things set up
onto the island to the island staff
provisions um
building of the the tents and and uh
organizing transportation of guests to
and from the island
when did you first hear that mr depp and
miss heard were getting married on the
island
calls for hearsay and relevance
what's the relevance when she heard
i can move on okay next question um what
communications of any did you have with
ms heard about the wedding
i
we were given um
information on a schedule
um to better help me schedule and the
provisioning of what would be
on the island beverages and food and
things like that we were given a
schedule for
daily
um
things were going to uh
happen each day
what time foods were when people were
coming in how many people would be at
meals just so we i had a better idea of
planning of what was happening um it was
detailed um it was
what was happening each day um on
and then it was uh the rehearsal night
and there would be you know we had
scheduled it would be dinner dancing
drugs music and then the wedding we were
very um
conscious about doing the wedding the
next day we were doing the wedding um
the ceremony and we
were specific on time privacy was very
important um we
were very careful of people taking
pictures i think everybody was given um
disposable cameras and asked not to take
pictures
um i was concerned about that also but
we were doing the um ceremony at um
sunset so there really wouldn't be uh
issue with
um
what paparazzi people and things like
that and um
shortly when the ceremony was about to
happen it actually happened earlier than
it was um scheduled the bridal party and
amber showed up early and we were still
scrambling for flowers and
setting up and getting beverages and
snacks down there and there was a plane
circling overhead and
it just kept on circling and circling
and taking pictures and the ceremony
proceeded earlier
than um was scheduled
did you observe mr depp drinking alcohol
at the wedding objection leading
all right i'll sustain the objection
okay
miss roberts as part of the provisioning
for the wedding did you
order alcohol for the wedding objection
leading sustained okay
miss roberts what did you order for the
wedding in february 2015
um i was i was given a list of
food
i was given a list of beverages for wine
champagnes i was asked to
have dr pepper and
sugar-free red bull here because at that
time that was what
mr depp or johnny was drinking
was dr pepper and sugar-free red bull
okay
um did you observe miss her drinking
alcohol the wedding
objection leading sustained
who did you observe drinking alcohol at
the wedding
um
pretty much everybody was was drinking
and doing shots and celebrating it was
it was a party
uh mr roberts i'd like to discuss with
you when mr depp and mr were on the
island in december 2015. who came down
to the island with them
um
i flew to nassau um to meet them which
is what i normally do um i meet
he himself johnny and and whoever comes
to the island i fly to nassau to meet
them just to make sure that the
transition is smooth with customs and
immigration
so i flew to nassau and i met
johnny amber his children and a friend
of their of the children
and um
load the luggage onto the
caravan plane and we boarded the plane
and and came to the island
and a couple days into the trip
alice and
greg and alice's three children and a
nanny came to the island as well
who are alice and greg
alice is a
clothes designer and greg
was her partner i believe he's a
photographer
when did you first interact with miss
heard when she came to the island in
december 2015.
i'm at the airport when i flew to nassau
to meet to meet everybody usually when
they come down off the plane you know
there's hugs and kisses and chatting for
a couple minutes while the luggage is
transferred
how close were you to miss herd
close hug close hug kiss you know how
are you talk same with everybody
so face to face cheek to cheek
what if any makeup did you observe miss
heard wearing when you first interacted
with her
i i don't recall
if she was or was not wearing makeup
she
she if she wore makeup it was very
natural um i i
don't think often she wore makeup on the
island um
i
i don't recall her wearing makeup
what if any injuries did you notice i
misheard
i didn't notice any
miss roberts you mentioned that gregory
a photographer came to the island during
that time
um how often did you observe gregory on
the island
um i interacted every day because uh
meals went down and and
and
and changing the sheets and cleaning the
room um so i i see everybody every day
um there and when you saw him what was
he doing
um
the they were doing there was a photo
shoot on the island um
amber was wearing the clothes amber was
wearing alice's clothes and they were
doing a photo shoot on the beach
um and greg was taking the pictures
okay
what if anything do you remember about
that particular time that mr depp and
miss heard came down to the island
we had a there was a
incident between johnny and amber
here during that trip
okay can you please describe that
incident
um i
on the evening we kind of called it a
night dinner was finished
we wrapped everything up down here at
the staff area in the kitchen
myself and cj
came to the office
later on that evening and johnny was
in the office up here
and he was agitated kind of walking back
and forth i had asked him if he needed
anything because i think i wasn't sure
why if he was up here to get something
or was looking for something which
wouldn't be unusual for people to come
up here um so he was here
we talked for a couple minutes the three
of us and a couple minutes later
amber
um
came into the into the office with um
into the office and we were the three of
us were in the office and amber came in
and she was asking him to
tell him to come back to the house um
please come back i'm sorry come back
um and uh he
stood
stood here reluctant to go um didn't
want to go
and um a little exchange back and forth
um he
left the office and got into his vehicle
and started it up and amber went outside
and stood in front of the vehicle
um so that
didn't drive away she was standing and
amber was standing in front of it and um
again it was she was asking him to don't
leave i'm sorry come back to the house
after a couple minutes um she got in the
vehicle and they left to go up back to
their house
what happened after they went back up to
the house
um cj and i were still in the office and
um weren't really sure
decided that maybe it would be best if
we just drove up there just to make sure
that
um
everything was okay and um so we got in
the golf cart and we drove up to the
house
go into the parking lot and the his
vehicle was in the parking lot and
um
you could hear them and you can hear
them inside you can hear inside the
house
yelling um
her amber yelling and and johnny
answering back and you could really hear
what was being said
um we stood there for a couple minutes
uh cj myself and then um
then you started to hear um it became
audible um amber was telling him that he
was a
uh washed-up actor
he was gonna die a lonely a fat lonely
old man then you heard uh you hit me
with a can you hear johnny say you hit
me with a can and then he came down the
steps
and amber was behind him
and she had a
bottle in her hand it was removed and
there was a brief pause at the moment i
think of initial shock or
uncertainty of why you know that we were
there i think
neither johnny nor amber knew that we
were there
um he proceeded
to
walk back to the john deere
and
um
she
again walked he was sitting in the seat
amber came up to him and was asking him
to come back in the house that she was
sorry please come back in the house
um
and uh
he didn't come out of the seat and she
was hugging and kissing him and i love
you i love you she was telling him i
loved you
he didn't react
johnny sat there
eventually uh got out of the john deere
um and proceeded to
start to walk away at that time amber
started to grab at him and his shirt
and and trying to pull him back to the
house um
just basically viciously trying to pull
him back and get him back in the house
and and and yelling at him and at that
point i i was between them and uh felt
it was
best and i was getting worried about
what was going to happen and it was best
that um
i remove him from the
situation and so um cj took
amber back to the house and i
walked johnny over to the cafe which was
basically 30 seconds away from from the
house because it was the only place i
could take him to at the time
and you mentioned that miss heard was
viciously trying to pull mr depp back
can you explain what you mean by that
um
it was like clawing grabbing in his
clothes grabbing his hair trying to like
pull him back like an angry like he was
leaving and come back he couldn't leave
in the vehicle because the keys had been
taken out
so there was there wasn't a way for
johnny to drive away the only way was
for
him to to what for him to walk away and
um
it
wasn't um a pleasant situation of of
wanting him to
to not leave and um
angry and yelling and just yelling you
know come back come back don't leave
um and things like that
at any point did mr depp um hit or touch
miss heard objection leading
all right seeing the objection
miss roberts um how did mr duff react to
miss heard viciously grabbing him
he he didn't uh he stood there with his
arms by his side and um
he
he didn't do anything
okay
mr roberts when you were back in the
cafe with mr depp what happened next
um
i was concerned because uh
he
i had heard and rejected
objection to her being concerned that
that's not responsible assistant is too
concerned all right okay mr roberts
without
testifying as how you felt um what did
you observe when you went back to the
cafe with mr deb
i when we went back to the cafe he had a
mark across the bridge of his nose um i
got a bag of ice to put on his on it so
that it wouldn't swell
um just to make sure that it wasn't
bleeding and i
he walked over to the love seat at the
cafe and he
laid down and
went to sleep and cj came back over and
um i asked cj to stay there for the
remainder of the evening for the
remainder of the morning
and i left cj inside the cafe and i left
johnny on the couch
when did you next see miss heard
that that morning i saw i saw her that
morning
how close were you to miss heard when
you interacted with her the next morning
uh conversation
um in in
a feet away
when you saw her how did she appear
um
they had guests leaving and uh it was uh
kind of a normal morning um
going down to the beach to see the
guests leave
what if any makeup was miss heard
wearing
again i'm not sure she
if she wore makeup on the island if it
was it was very natural looking
what if any injuries did you observe on
this herd
i didn't observe any
what if any injuries did you observe on
mr dap
the
the marking across the bridge of his
nose
after
and um when did miss hurt and mr duck
leave the island
i believe they left that afternoon the
guests left in the morning and i believe
they left that afternoon
after miss hurt and mr depp left the
island what did you do next
um our usual we go into the buildings
and uh we break them down we empty out
the refrigerators garbage take all the
perishables out of the house um
straighten the place up take the linens
away
um things like that
what did you observe when you went
through that process
um the island was
the island was as it was when they
arrived the only
thing that was different was the there
was the liquid on the on the deck with a
can i believe of mineral spirits or
something there next to it which had
leaked out onto the deck and then in the
um
over the railing
were
paint brushes and
art supplies paintbrushes
paint tubes
the jars of the paints are in and those
were all scattered in the bush
mr roberts when is the first time you
provided testimony about this incident
in december 2015.
i believe it was for another case in may
2020.
miss roberts how often have you seen mr
depp drink alcohol in the island
um he goes through periods of time where
he's been here and he doesn't drink and
it's non-alcoholic backs or something
like that
it varies
sometimes he drinks when he's here
sometimes he doesn't
how often have you seen miss heard drink
alcohol on the island
um she she drank wine she drank wine
with her
her drink was wine with dinner
maybe in the afternoon but i know
definitely with dinner
did you observe miss heard drinking
alcohol when mr depp was not drinking
alcohol objection leading no sustained
misleading okay
um
how often have you seen mr depp drunk
um
i wouldn't know he's a huge tolerance
for alcohol i haven't seen him passed
out drunk um or anything like that so i
uh
he drinks
but i haven't seen him passed out drunk
okay
thank you miss roberts nothing further
all right cross-examination thank you
your honor
ms roberts the salary you receive
for managing the bahama island is
approximately ten thousand dollars a
month correct
correct okay and so that comes out to
120 000 a year
correct okay and you've been and you've
been receiving that salary for many
years correct
correct right in fact i think you gotta
raise to ten thousand ten dollars in
2018.
do you remember that
no i i don't know the exact number but i
know i get that that a month okay and
that's and that's in addition to all of
the expenses correct
for running the the expenses
of running the island
i get a salary every month
i'm not sure what you're asking me so
the the other people that are on the
island to the extent they work they get
a different salary right
yes okay and all of the expenses you
have you talked about what you have to
do
to provision the island and everything
else and run it all of those expenses
are paid separately correct
correct okay
and you said you've been managing this
island for 15 years for mr depp is that
correct
approximately yes all right now let's
talk for a moment about those two videos
that you you testified to were part of
the house the first video was missing
both the closet and the bathroom correct
i i
i don't remember i'd have to look at it
again all right and the second
sorry go ahead
go ahead i'm sorry you didn't come
through go ahead
no i'm sorry i think the in the first
video the beads were the closet and then
there was the bathroom next to the
closet okay that was the stream
that was the second video
do you know sorry do you know who took
those videos
oh i did okay when did you take those
videos
oh it would have to be
i'm not sure a couple years ago maybe
longer okay
i'm not sure okay did you take those
videos for the uk trial
i i don't recall if it was for that
is there a reason that the closet and
the bathroom were left out of the first
video
no i
know i stood in the house and did a
circle around of the house
okay
who asked you to make that video
i'm not sure i'm not sure
was it mr waldman
adam waldman
i i don't i'm not sure i don't know
can't recall i can't remember who asked
me no i can't okay now the second video
that shows the closet and then there's a
door there would you agree that door
opens up into a bathroom
next to the closet yes okay and we don't
have a video of the the bathroom correct
i don't believe
there was a video of the bathroom and no
one asked you to make a video of the
bathroom correct objection relevance
i'll overrule it
correct
oh sorry um i'm not sure if anybody
asked me to i don't believe i videotaped
the bathroom
and my question was and no one asked you
to videotape the bathroom correct
correct okay
now let's talk for a moment about the
logistics of the island
so mr depp's house we've seen the inside
of and you said that the cafe
was a 30-second walk i think you said
how many yards
i don't know i walk it it's it's
just outside his house through the
parking lot and
uh walkway to the cafe okay
okay and the cafe
is where
mr depp would regularly have his meals
correct
correct all the guests would have their
meals there okay including mr depp and
miss hurt if she was there and their
children
correct
correct okay and then yes
and then you were located on the other
side of the island correct that's where
you stay
are i stay in in the middle of the
island yes okay how far away is that
from the cafe in the house
objection compounds
i'll sustain the objections
how far away is it from the house
where i i stay yes
um
probably a
three-minute golf cart ride okay
five-minute walk okay uh and then when
other guests come i think you were
talking about tents
do they stay in tents
no
the tents were
um
the tents were erected for the the
wedding and then they were dismantled
and sometimes we would erect them if we
were asked to just in case somebody
wanted to stay there but people didn't
stay in the tents they stayed in the
buildings here okay so how
how much accommodation can you handle in
the buildings for other guests
i'm not talking about the house mr
depp's house we've seen that um but how
many people can can actually be
accommodated
in the buildings
we have a
two-bedroom
uh yurt on brando beach we have a
um
a beach house which has uh the bed in it
and then we have uh um
what we call a round house which has a
bed in it as well
okay now when mr depp and ms heard were
visiting
whether they had the children there or
not
typically
would you bring the meals to the cafe
for each of the meals
though sometimes i would take them to
the house it depended on where they
wanted to eat
all right and then typically would you
join them for the meal or would you
leave the meal and then come back and
clean up afterwards objection compound
all right
i'll sustain the objection all right
we'll take that one at a time
typically would you bring the meals
to them
myself
myself or one of the the they got the
workers here would take the meals okay
how often was it you that would take him
um
how often
maybe every other day every day it
depended on on how if people were eating
in their buildings or eating together
all right and would you stay and eat the
meal with them or would you leave
if we were invited for dinner we would
all eat together usually we would take
the food to the places and leave okay
and then
would you be called to come pick them up
no no we would sometimes go back in the
evenings
on our own um and and clean up and turn
some of the lights off and sometimes we
would do it in the morning depending on
what was happening okay
so other than bringing the meals and it
could be you or somebody else
how often did you interact with mr depp
and ms heard during the days
when they were on the island
on average every day
in what context other than delivering
the meals and picking them up
oh just see if anything was needed if
everything was all right um things like
that um generally passing them if they
were walking or in the office or or
on the beach
okay
now
would it be fair to say
that you weren't spending 24 7 with them
no i didn't live with them no okay and
would it be fair to say that you don't
know what they were doing during the
times that you weren't passing them by
or bringing meals
yes unless they were on the beach okay
then i would know but so you wouldn't
know what happened what would be taking
place within the house for example when
you weren't there
correct
correct and you wouldn't know whether mr
depp was taking drugs correct
correct and you wouldn't know whether mr
depp was drinking correct
i would only know by cleaning up okay
and you wouldn't know
well you wouldn't know from cleaning
that necessarily whether it was mr dab
ms hurd or somebody else would you
objection compound
overrule out loud go ahead
please continue
unless um i would know what it was by
what was in the garbage or left out of
who consumed or what was consumed i
would i would be able to know okay and
you wouldn't know
what arguments if there were any were
taking place in that house behind closed
doors right
correct and you wouldn't know whether
there was any kind of physical abuse
that was taking place behind those
closed doors correct
i wouldn't know correct okay
now let me just take you for a moment to
the december 2015
time frame
how
how
much advance notice are you typically
given
for
when they are when mr depp and his
entourage are going to arrive and for
how long they're going to stay
objection compound
all right i'll
i'll sustain the objection
all right let's break it down how much
notice are you given when mr depp and
his entourage are coming
it varies
sometimes it's a couple days sometimes
it's a couple weeks so how much notice
were you given in december of 2015
to who would be coming for christmas on
the bahama island
i believe um sometime in november okay
for that trip
all right and in november
how many people were you told were
coming for christmas
on the island
i don't recall how many i don't recall
how many people it was a lot more than
amber johnny
lily rose jack and lily rose's boyfriend
wasn't it
yes it was
in fact it was amber's parents correct
i believe so and it was rocky pennington
and josh drew
correct
i believe they were on the list and
rocky pennington's parents
yes i believe they were on the list
do you recall
them canceling
objection here's thing i recall
how is that here all over the objection
go ahead
i recall
there was a change um
to
the
the guests
when did you learn of that
i don't recall maybe a couple weeks
after maybe beginning of december maybe
middle of december do you sure do you
recall if it was after december 15
i don't recall
did you think that was a little strange
that here these people were going to be
christmas on the island and suddenly
they cancel objection relevance
i think it's highly relevant i'll
sustain the objection
next question
what if anything were you told about why
they canceled objection hearsay
party opponent admission that
you lay foundation for that okay
who told you
that amber's parents her best friend and
fiance and her best friend's
parents
were suddenly canceling coming for
christmas on the island objection
compound
i allow that good
i
don't know who
um
told me but i did receive a mat i did
receive information that um
they weren't coming and there were other
somebody else was coming instead
and who was that somebody else coming
instead
um that it would be alice and
it would be alice and greg and the
children and nanny and they were coming
later right
they would be joining that i think was
the words
okay
so
on the december 5th on the december trip
you testified about a few arguments
between amber and johnny right do you
recall that testimony
yes i do okay you weren't present
when johnny sustained the gash on his
nose correct
i wasn't there no okay and you weren't
present
when the
mess was made through the paints that
you've described correct
no and so you don't know
whether there had been a physical
altercation
and
that led to throwing a paint can to try
to slow down johnny right
no i just heard yelling in the house
okay
but that
that yelling in the house
wasn't necessarily the same time was it
you don't know do you no it was all the
same
okay no
okay
now let's talk about
the summer of
2013.
are you aware that paul bettany claims
he's never met amber
objection relevance
and call for
she testified that he was there on the
island and calls for hearsay
i i can ask the question and see if she
says all right i'll allow the question
go ahead
can you repeat it are you aware that
paul bettany has said that he never met
amber heard
no i'm unaware okay i didn't know that
well let's stay on the summer of 2013 if
we can do you have a recollection
of amber and johnny lily rose and jack
taking one final trip on the yacht that
johnny was going to be selling to jk
rowling
i don't know what year that was i i
don't know what year that was but i do
remember the yacht being sold if i if i
tell you it was july of 2013 does that
help refresh your recollection
july 9
yeah
all right now
it doesn't i just know the yacht was
sold okay and you made arrangements did
you not for a captain to to
captain the yacht and for them to go out
on the yacht
no i didn't have any responsibility for
the yacht and the crew on the yard okay
do you have a recollection
of being called
because lily rose and jack were upset
and they wanted to leave the yacht and
have a helicopter take them away
objection hearsay and compound i'm
asking whether she has a recollection of
this i'll allow the question
can you ask me again do you have a
recollection
of lily rose and jack being upset on the
yacht
and wanting to leave it immediately so
you arranged for a helicopter to come in
to fly them away with amber objection
compound
i'll allow it okay
i i don't know
if lily rose and jack were upset
i do know that
i did arrange for transportation off the
island
at the time
and
and in fact amber went with lily rose
correct
it was amber and her friend and lily
rose okay and jack decided at the last
minute to stay back correct
i don't know if he decided last minute
he stayed okay do you recall lily rose
telling you that she was upset because
her father was drinking and trying to
hide it from him objection hearsay
i'm asking whether she has sustained the
objection okay
um then i'll ask the next one
do you recall
mr depp passing out in the sand face
first
i recall that he was uh passed out on
the beach he was he was yeah he was out
on the beach yes okay and and do you
recall jack calling you because he was
concerned
objection here saying that's just asking
if he called i haven't asked what he
said no
you did i'll sustain the objection okay
do you have a recollection of
jack being present
when mr depp was passed out face first
in the sand
yes
and do you have a recollection of jack
being upset
i i i don't have a reaction of him being
upset you have a recollection of him
being happy about it
i
i
no i i didn't speak with with jack
about it okay
but you recall that mr depp was passed
out face first in the sand correct
objection asked and answered i'll
sustain the objection next question all
right thank you
let's talk about makeup for a moment
so
you don't
know what type of makeup regimen amber
uses every day correct
correct okay and in fact you don't know
you said at one point you're not sure
but it's a natural look do you recall
that
yes i do okay and would you agree that
there are a number of different types of
makeup you can use that would still
give you a natural
look
objection calls for speculation
i'll allow it
i i i'm guessing there is yes okay okay
and and there's sun in the bahamas right
most of the time
do you know what amber wears
for sunscreen
um i think it was
at one point i had a brand shishido or
something like that that was on the
island
that we provided
and do you know whether amber brought
her own as well
i don't know do you know whether amber
had a skin condition
i wasn't told
okay
but you i take it you didn't ask
no i wouldn't have asked if somebody had
skin condition
okay
the wedding
the wedding was planned at sunset
correct
correct and in fact it went forward at
sunset correct
it went um earlier
it was it was earlier than in
sunset so your recollection is that
there's no sunset pictures at the
wedding
okay there was it was yeah there was
sunset pictures
okay
so uh last couple questions
the uh the makeup or not makeup you were
asked whether you observed any injuries
on amber in the december 2015 time frame
do you believe amber would cover up
bruises
to hide them from the kids
objection calls for circulation
do you have any understanding based on
your knowledge of amber whether she
would try to cover up
any bruises or cuts same objections from
the kids i'll sustain the objection
i you said that you didn't believe that
that amber was wearing much makeup but
you said she participated in a photo
shoot in december 2015 do you recall
that
yes i do do you know whether amber was
wearing any makeup for a photo shoot
i'm not sure the the part that i saw she
was in and out of the water
do you do you know whether amber would
want to show bruises or cuts in a photo
shoot objection calls for speculation
i'll sustain the objection i have no
further questions thank you all right
redirect
me too
thank you
miss roberts how many times have you
seen mr depp consume drugs objection
leading all right sustained
um
mrs barnhoff asked you about um mr depp
passed out on the beach how would you
describe mr depp when you saw him on the
beach
um he was he was passed out i picked him
up and brushed muffins and he said i
left him underneath the
i believe he was in a hammock and i
i believe he'd fallen asleep or he was
asleep and the hammock had overturned
um and i picked him up and
brushed him off and
left him
on underneath the lanai with jack
okay no further questions thank mrs
roberts subject to recall mr roberts
yes potentially
miss robertson you're subject to recall
did not discuss your testimony with
anybody and just not watch anything
about this uh case okay ma'am
thank you okay thank you very much all
right thank you
all right your next witness
dr shannon curry she'll come right now
doctor who shannon curry can you is it
c-u-r-r-y c-u-r-r-y okay thank you
so
um
okay
there
truthfully in this case a penalty of law
good morning dr curry good morning
i'm wayne dennison
could you state your full name for the
record
shannon curry
what do you do for a living
i am a clinical and forensic
psychologist
what's your educational background
i received well i started college at
georgetown university
i then transferred to the university of
california irvine where i received my
bachelor's degree in psychology and
social behavior
i completed my master's degree in
psychology at the
pepperdine university
i went on to complete my doctoral degree
in clinical psychology at pepperdine
university which included several
training rotations at different
practicum sites those are essentially
clinical rotations we do to learn
various types of psychology you learn
how to do psychological assessment
counseling etc and you do that in a
variety of different settings
and then i completed a year-long
doctoral internship at an american
psychological association accredited
doctoral internship you do this year
before you get your degree and that was
at tripler army medical center
it's traditionally a military internship
they did admit to civilians i was lucky
enough to be one of them
i then completed two years of
postdoctoral training at hawaii state
hospital a locked forensic psychology
facility and that's where you
essentially have individuals with severe
mental illness who have committed crimes
have you done any additional uh
coursework or educational work
i have so uh after i completed my
doctorate and my postdoctoral training
i obtained a it's called a postdoctoral
master of science degree and clinical
psychopharmacology
that is
for partial fulfillment of prescription
privileges meaning that it's part of
what we need to be able to prescribe
medications as a psychologist because
psychologists don't traditionally
prescribe and we can do that with
certain military jurisdictions and other
states
i also obtained
advanced training in the gottman method
of couples therapy
i completed all three levels of training
and then i'm also a gottman educator for
several workshops involving uh helping
parents learn how to prepare to bring
their baby home and
uh helping couples without serious
problems improve their relationships
what's the gottman method
the gottman method is a
highly researched based uh method of
couples therapy it's very structured so
different than what many people expect
when they think about couples therapy i
always tell my clients i don't want them
to come in just tell each other all
their problems and then have an awkward
silent drive home in this therapy they
come in they complete a really
structured assessment in the beginning
so they complete a bunch of questions it
gives me a ton of information about
their relationship before we even get
started and really identifies the areas
we're going to target with structured
interventions during each session i
think of it almost like a class
okay
um
did you get in the course of your
education any specialized training
any what specialized training
i did so uh
my internship specifically was dedicated
to
essentially working with post-traumatic
stress disorder traumatic stress
a lot of my training has been with
psychological assessment and testing and
then my training during practicum and
then in my post-doctoral work was
dedicated to working with trauma
populations and also conducting forensic
psychological assessments oftentimes
forensic psychological assessments
actually refers to doing testing in an
interview and a couple other things for
purposes related to law so it's the
application of psychology to the courts
to legal issues
and sometimes that also involves uh
doing assessments for the military to
determine whether somebody has sustained
a mental disability after combat
um you indicated that you did some work
at tripler what's tripler and what's the
work you did
so tripler army medical center is a
hospital in honolulu hawaii if anybody's
ever gotten to have a vacation in hawaii
it's a giant pink building there and
it's one of the top training sites for
military psychologists i was very very
lucky to be able to train there they
have wonderful funding and a lot of new
research going on particularly for ptsd
but really for all areas of mental
health
while i was there i did rotations in
family psychology so doing family
therapy i worked with children but i
also did a neuropsychology rotation
learning really the ins and outs of
advanced psychological assessment
identifying not just mental issues
mental
sort of mental illness but also
traumatic brain injuries after trauma
and doing those ptsd evaluations and
then also working with service members
who were struggling with a whole host of
issues military stressors normal life
stressors and then also those who
sustained tremendous uh trauma from
combat
do you still continue to work with the
military i do actually our practice
i
my practice is very focused on military
service members veterans and their
families
okay
um
what work have you done
in prior
litigation matters
well
uh most of my litigation if we're
talking about civil work
that has mostly been reports so this is
my first time testifying in a civil
matter uh the majority of my forensic
work has been in criminal law or
providing psychological assessments and
then i produce a really methodical
report
which is typically reviewed by a judge
and a determination is made or usually
there's a settlement
beforehand
okay
um
do you
work uh in connection with with any
particular courts
i do so i i am actually not sure if i'm
on the list anymore in honolulu but
i am a certified forensic evaluator for
the state of hawaii which means that
i have been appointed by the court to
conduct evaluations for matters that are
presented
and then i'm also on
the list of forensic evaluators in
several courts in southern california
and then i'm also i'm contracted by the
military the department of defense uh
now and again for evaluations of ptsd
from service members okay you mentioned
uh ptsd a couple of times now
yes what are you referring to there
so ptsd is a mental illness um
it can develop after a person has been
exposed to a traumatic event and
our diagnostic statistical manual the
dsm is sort of the authoritative manual
of mental illnesses we it's considered
our bible of mental illness we go there
for diagnoses and according to that
there's a specific type of trauma that a
person must experience for them to be
able to qualify for a diagnosis of ptsd
and that's an event that is
life-threatening it can also involve
sexual assault and you can experience
that either directly but you can also be
traumatized if you've seen it happen to
somebody else or if it's happened
unexpectedly or violently to somebody
close to you a family member or friend
and then there's also a provision for
people who are first responders if
they're encountering really traumatic
information regularly
that qualifies as a trauma now there are
a number of symptoms that can develop
sure we'll talk about that okay um
do you hold any credentials relevant to
the work that you do
well i am a licensed psychologist
um where
in california and hawaii
[Music]
okay and any other certifications or
other credentials
not that i can think of off the top of
my head other other than the training
with the gottman method of couples
therapy okay
have you worked with the hawaii
department of courts and corrections
yes i have in what capacity i am i so
that i guess would be a credential so i
am a certified forensic evaluator for
the state of hawaii
in connection with your doctorate was
there a research component there was so
uh would you like me to tell you about
it yes please okay
so i conducted a research study while i
was at pepperdine completing my
doctorate it's called a dissertation so
when you're obtaining your doctorate you
contribute something to the scientific
field that you're in and typically that
involves doing what we call novel
science so you're doing an experiment
you're finding out new information and
helping the field progress
so i did research in peru and i was
essentially looking at the effectiveness
of a therapy intervention there for kids
who were growing up in this community
called ayakucho which was exposed to 20
years of guerrilla warfare the longest
guerrilla war in the history of the
world and there were a lot of issues in
that community
tremendous trauma and my research was
around
finding interventions that were really
effective for that community
where do you work now
i work for the curry psychology group
what does the curry psychology group do
we're a multi-specialty mental health
center so we have neuropsychologists who
do testing for kids we have therapists
individual therapists couples therapists
family therapists we even have a
meditation teacher we basically try to
meet the needs of our community and we
highly specialize in working with
military personnel and their families
who's the korean
curry psychology group
i i'm dr curry
how many people work for you
as of right now i believe it's 13.
how long have you been doing this kind
of work
for about 15 years
how much of your therapy practice
focuses on treating individuals
i would say about half of it as
individuals half his couples
okay
do you do any training of students
i do
what's that
so uh we have several unlicensed
professionals at our office and
they're earning their additional hours
so that they can get licensed so they're
able to see clients and then i meet with
them regularly to supervise them discuss
their cases provide them with
information about different diagnoses
interventions and treatment methods
how did you get involved in this case
i was contacted by ms camille vasquez
one of the attorneys for mr depp
okay and
what was the nature of the contact
miss
vazquez called me and indicated um that
she might be interested in having me
meet the legal team so that i could
discuss my expertise and possibly
provide my opinions related to the
matter
what were you asked to provide uh expert
opinion on
so initially uh my role that i
understood at the time was to review the
case materials and
provide my opinions regarding anything
that i noticed that was consistent or
even inconsistent with the psychological
science
that exists today on intimate partner
violence in mr deb mishard's
relationship
right you used a phrase there uh
intimate partner violence what are you
talking about
so there are a
multitude of different definitions
depending on the source or the state
but essentially intimate partner
violence is abuse it could be physical
psychological uh
and it's from one partner to another in
an intimate relationship
okay
um
did your role in this case evolve over
time
yes uh it shifted so i was retained uh
in at the end of january 2021
and then uh
just barely begun to review the
documents the case was postponed and
then in october
2021
i was asked
by
council to provide a psychological
evaluation of misheard
okay
did uh
were you ever asked to do an uh
psychological psychological evaluation
of mr depp
no
okay
what
types of documents did you consider in
this analysis
so i reviewed
quite a few documents as part of my
evaluation
that included
all of the case documents
ms herd's medical records by dr kipper
her prior mental health treatment
records i believe i reviewed records
from
dr amy banks
dr bonnie jacobs dr cohen connell cohen
[Music]
and also a significant portion of my
review involved
notes from nurse aaron fellotti at the
time aaron borum who spent a significant
time with ms herd in her direct company
i also reviewed exhibits
quite a few audio recordings a video
recording several video recordings or
possibly photographs i might be getting
them confused
um and multiple witness statements
testimony and um declarations
did there come a time when you met
directly with ms hurt
yes i did so in conducting my evaluation
i met with miss heard on two separate
dates december 10th and december 17th
2021.
uh approximately how much time have you
spent with miss heard
so the evaluation uh we spent 12 hours
directly with one another um however
there were more there were more hours
involved in the evaluation with some
breaks so we spent seven hours together
on the first day december 10th um
not necessarily together because there
was a one-hour lunch break and about a
half hour with breaks split up through
the day and then on the 17th we spent a
little more than eight hours in the
evaluation from start to finish with a
one-hour break and another half hour of
breaks distributed throughout the day
as there was as a result of the work
that you performed did you form any
opinions
with respect to ms heard i did
what were those opinions
i uh
the results of ms herd's evaluation
supported two diagnoses borderline
personality disorder and histrionic
personality disorder
what is
a diagnosis
a diagnosis is a way that we essentially
that psychologist psychiatrist anybody
in the mental health field
thinks about a disorder it helps us to
communicate a set of symptoms that a
person is experiencing and along with
that set of symptoms it it tells other
professionals a lot about how those
symptoms might have developed how that
person might behave perceive the world
um it also drives treatment the real
purpose is to determine what sort of
interventions will be most effective for
the person
yeah
um
previously you made reference to uh i
think you called it the dsm-5
yes
so the dsm-5 that stands for the
diagnostic statistical manual
version 5
and
that contains every diagnosis we use in
mental health and
we it's
it's the authoritative manual of mental
diagnosis
is uh performing diagnosis something you
typically do in your line of work
yes
thank you
so
your reference to personality disorders
what's a personality disorder
to understand a personality disorder i
think it can be helpful first to kind of
define personality
so personality something we take for
granted but these are the traits the
characteristics the way we think we feel
and we act
that make us who we are and these traits
are pretty stable over time and across
situations we might uh you know be sure
to mind our p's and q's when we're
meeting somebody new but overall if
somebody were to describe us or if we
were to describe ourselves we have a
pretty good sense of who we are
sometimes an easy way to think of it is
imagining how you might describe a
brother or sister or a child if you have
children their personalities are pretty
clear to you a personality disorder
is some sort of dysfunction
in those enduring traits so as opposed
to other types of mental illness
when you think about something like
depression that's episodic it comes and
it goes and when it's treated with
medication it can pretty much be
completely mitigated or minimized in a
person's life and their personality is
still there separate from the depression
when we have a personality disorder
they're going to be disturbances
in several different areas that are
visible in almost all different facets
of their life
is there a manner in which
personality disorders are commonly
diagnosed
yes so they can be diagnosed in a
treating environment a treating
psychologist or a therapist or a
psychiatrist simply does a diagnostic
interview which involves assessing
multiple areas of a person's history
back down through child i'm going to
stop you for a second what's a treating
environment
sometimes i'll slip into these words i
apologize so a treating environment in
therapy if somebody is going in for
treatment um
the psycho the mental health provider
will ask them questions to find out what
sort of symptoms they've experienced and
what sort of things have occurred in
their life that might be consistent with
these disorders or rule out these
disorders prove that there is no reason
for these disorders to be considered
they might also pay attention to their
observations of the client over time and
new information the client provides them
the most reliable way however to ever
come about a diagnosis really is through
a
comprehensive psychological assessment
and i might use the words assessment
examination testing interchangeably they
all mean the same thing it's combining
information from multiple different
sources
one main source is psychological testing
using validated objective measures that
means that they've been tested they've
been shown to be accurate for testing
what you want to test
and in the environment you're testing so
there are measures specific for court
environments where someone might respond
differently you integrate that with the
same interview i was telling you that
people would do for therapy we do that
as well
and then in a courtroom setting you're
going to look at all the legal records
all of those documents corroborating
information to sort of check your
hypotheses that may be developing and
also check against the examinee
statements to confirm
whether you have enough evidence of a
certain diagnosis
so what's a clinical interview
a clinical interview is a very
comprehensive interview it includes a
person's entire life history
as well as very specifically looks at
any symptoms they might have this can
start as far back as birth you might
find out if there were any issues with
their delivery
any
genetic issues any intellectual issues
how did they do what was their home life
like how is discipline handled what's
their relationship with their primary
caregivers were they raised by an aunt
an uncle their parents how many siblings
do they have how do they get along with
their siblings how many times did they
have to move were was there any abuse
did they have any really significant
life experiences that come to mind when
they think about their childhood how
were they as a student did they need
special services did they get in trouble
at school and you do this you continue
on high school what were their hobbies
did they play sports how many friends
did they have did they have any trouble
keeping those friendships then you get
into adulthood did they go to college
did they not go to college how come what
sort of jobs have they held how did
those jobs go how did they end that's
always an important question what sort
of romantic relationships have they been
involved in how do they identify
sexually culturally
let's see what else what sort of
symptoms have they experienced
you go through the entire gamut of some
of the main symptoms you might screen
for depression
any disorganized thinking that means
thinking that isn't necessarily in touch
with reality
and uh any current distress they may be
happy
having today
how did you conclude that misheard
suffers from the personality disorders
that you identified
so
there was information that supported it
from multiple sources
i conducted testing including
one of the main tests that i used
she obtained scores that were consistent
with those diagnoses and then i also
there was evidence of those diagnoses in
her records and in her self-report
okay
all right council why don't we just go
ahead and pause for a second while we go
and take our morning recess okay ladies
and gentlemen we'll go ahead and take
our 15 minute morning recess do not
discuss the case and do not do any
outside research okay
your honor when would you like to
reconvene uh give me a moment sir
and dr since you're on the stand now do
not discuss your testimony with anybody
to include the attorneys at this point
okay all right let's go ahead and we'll
come back at 11 45. okay all right
ready for the jury
okay
all right you have your seat
and your next question sir
thank you your honor
uh
dr curry before the break uh you were
talking about some of the
factors that you considered in
determining uh that misheard suffers
from personality disorders and one of
them i think the last one you said
before you left was self-report what do
you mean by that
so
uh
the self-report would be things that
misheard indicated to me specifically
so there were a couple of
characteristics that she noted in
herself report that were consistent with
these personality disorders
the first was actually my own behavioral
observations of her based on her
self-report so
one of the hallmark characteristics of
histrionic borderline or sorry
histrionic personality disorder
is sort of a
overly dramatic presentation we call
this impressionistic speech so it tends
to be very flowery it uses a lot of
descriptive words like magical wonderful
and it can go on for quite some time and
yet it really lacks any substance so at
the end you're left wondering what was
just said or what the answer is to the
actual question so that occurred a
number of times
and it also represented the kind the
quick shifts you'll see between emotions
so
she would suddenly be one way and then
she would become very animated
or
very
sad and when people are displaying these
emotions with this personality disorder
it there's a sense of shallowness to it
people who are observing them will feel
like uh it's almost play acting and they
might not be able to put their finger on
it but part of it is because of the
rapidness with which the person can
switch emotions and also the lack of
substance they don't really refer to i
feel this way they might describe
emotions they might describe events but
very rarely and i miss her did not say i
feel
vulnerable she never really indicated a
vulnerable feeling of her own
then the substance of herself reports so
when i was asking her information about
her history
we're going to ask more about that later
i was just trying to get a sense of what
a self-report was oh okay um
what psychological tests did you perform
okay so psychological tests i uh i'll
just go in order so first of all i asked
her a couple questions from something
called the mini mental status exam
that's really just a fancy way of saying
that i wanted to make sure that she was
alert and oriented to we call it person
place and time that means she knew who
she was she knew who i was she knew
where we were and she knew the date that
make that way i can ensure that she's
able to participate in the evaluation
and understand what's happening
i then um
administered something called the
minnesota multiphasic personality
inventory two the two means that it's
the second edition and this is something
we call an objective measure so
it
asks 567
questions more statements and the person
either agrees or disagrees with them how
much the statement represents them
and this test has been around since 1943
there are more than 10 000 studies
showing that it is appropriate for
determining somebody's personality
traits
it measures all of those things i sort
of mentioned how a person thinks feels
and behaves in multiple different
aspects of their lives it also measures
very accurately
any signs of mental illness or
dysfunction and the reason i also really
like this test whenever you're using a
test for an evaluation that's going to
be used in a forensic setting
people have a lot of incentive to
present themselves in a way that's going
to benefit their case
and they may want to look like they're
sicker than they really are they may
want to look much healthier than they
really are and some of those um
incentives they may not even realize
that they're intending to do that so it
can be conscience conscious or unco
conscious but you really need to have a
test that can check for that
and the mmpi two has a set of validity
scales we call them these are scales
that measure really the truthfulness and
accuracy with which a person is
approaching the test
and these these scales on this
particular test have been so well
researched over many decades that
they've become very nuanced and they can
tell us a lot about
if somebody's for instance exaggerating
are they elevating one of the scales
that shows that they're exaggerating on
purpose are they exaggerating in a
manner that's more like a cry for help
are they exaggerating in a manner that's
clever and sophisticated or more obvious
and then the same exact thing goes for
trying to minimize symptoms we have a
number of scales that can show us all
the different if somebody's trying to
say they're the most wonderful person on
earth or if they're just trying to deny
problems and if they're doing that again
in a very clever way or more of an
obvious way so that test was my choice
for this case there's one other reason
i'd like to add is that part of my
evaluation was
one of the reasons was to assess whether
ms heard has post traumatic stress
disorder which i told you about earlier
as a result of the incidents that she's
alleged occurred by mr dev
and
that's a really tough disorder to find
out if somebody's faking it or not it's
one of the most easily faked disorders
most of us know what it feels like to
feel anxious and a lot of people have
seen war movies and movies that depict
somebody having ptsd in fact some
research has shown that if you give
someone a diagnostic checklist and said
show that you have ptsd they can do it
96 percent of the time to someone on the
street
so you really need a test that's very
sensitive to that and the mmpi 2 has
been shown in multiple studies to be
excellent at detecting those attempts
okay you keep using mmpi too that's the
abbreviation that you folks use for
them i'm sorry if i hadn't said that
that's the minnesota multiphasic
personality inventory
uh
what other
psychological testing did you perform
so i also performed the
clinician-administered ptsd scale dash
five and that dash five links it to the
diagnosis for ptsd in our current
diagnostic manual the fifth version
to do that test you first administer
something called the life events
checklist and the life events checklist
both of these tests by the way were
developed by the national center for
ptsd with the department of veterans
affairs
but the life events checklist lists 16
different very stressful life events
that people can go through that are
often can be associated with developing
ptsd and then it also has a 17th item
that you can fill in if you feel like
you've been through something really
difficult that wasn't included
now i like to also add something called
the life events checklist 5 interview
which digs a little bit deeper into the
person's childhood as well to find out
if they what sort of there are so many
different things that can be difficult
growing up
and also it's very important that you
have the person
which of the events they've listed let's
say they have a number of different
types of traumas which one do they feel
like
was the most traumatic for them which
one still causes them to feel distressed
when they talk about it
and sometimes they can't just identify
one and then that has a that leads to
your next decision so if they have
multiple different similar types of
events like scene combat
then you might
use that as the worst one the multiple
similar so
that looks like
you describe an anchor we call it to do
the testing and we would maybe describe
the anchor as
the worst of my combat experience
okay
now somebody had multiple different
traumas from different times in their
life like childhood abuse and then went
to combat and had some horrible things
happen there you would do
the clinician-administered ptsd scale
test
the one that comes after
you do one for the childhood event and a
separate one for the adulthood event
does this
clinician-administered ptsd scale have a
handy abbreviation it does
we'll call it the caps five that that's
actually what it goes by
okay
um
how common is the use of the mppi mmpi
ii in your profession
the mmpi 2 is actually the most commonly
used assessment worldwide by mental
health professionals and in forensic
settings for the court why did you use
it i used it for that purpose and for
its excellent validity in those settings
across genders across ethnicities um for
different reasons and um when i keep
saying validity by the way what i mean
is accuracy or
and i'll try to work that in but then
also for detecting the accuracy with
which a person reports ptsd
okay
um
is that scaled in some way
i'm sorry what was that does that make
use of a scale in some way
the mmpi too do you mean specifically
for ptsd
yes
there's actually a combination of scales
you want to look for you would never
make the diagnosis just based on one
scale alone or even on the test alone
you'd integrate other data
how did you administer the mmpi 2 to ms
hurt
i provided her the test on an ipad she
essentially had her own little desk area
and then an ipad she hits start it
provides her with the instructions and
then the it gives her 567 statements in
order for each one she taps true or
false
what did you learn about misheard from
the results of the mfpi too
quite a bit i um i wrote up a 25-page
interpretation outline
it has
numerous numerous scales so one of the
reasons i like this measure so much is
that it can tell you so much about
multiple different traits and tendencies
and mental issues um
one of the primary things i learned was
that she had a very uh sophisticated way
of minimizing any personal problems
um
i also learned that she tends to
well there were a number of
characteristics that were consistent
with the eventual diagnosis
but
some of the primary characteristics and
i'm going to try to condense 25 pages
here
were essentially
externalization of blame
tending to have a lot of inner hostility
that is attempted to be controlled
um
a tendency to be very self-righteous but
to also deny that self-righteousness and
to judge others um critically uh against
these sort of high standards for moral
value but also to deny doing that
essentially
to claim that one is uh
very non-judgmental and accepting and
yet very full of rage really and um and
these aren't facts but
her scores essentially correlated so
they were consistent with other people
who obtained these scores who have been
shown through many many many studies to
have these very specific traits so
externalization of blame
a lot of inner anger and hostility
sometimes that anger among these groups
with similar scores these people might
have that anger kind of explode out at
times they tend to be very
passive-aggressive
they may be self-indulgent very
self-centered
they
could use
manipulation tactics to try to get their
needs met very needy of attention
acceptance approval
they tend to
distance people who are close to them
initially they may seem very charming
they're very socially sophisticated
actually that was a major component on
there
they have a capacity to kind of
offer
some of their faults but
in a way but only the ones that people
think of lightly and can all relate to
and so they can present as very fair
imbalance but in actuality they really
might uh
be very judgmental of others and unaware
of problems in their behavior and their
thinking
so after you uh provide the the
examination
by the ipad what do you do
so
once they've completed the test
you can have it scored by the computer
immediately
it's a very very complex test to
interpret but right away you get a list
of what's called critical items and
these are just some
a couple of the items the statements
that are presented that are more
clearly symptom-based and i always
follow up with the examinee some of
these might have to do with suicide some
of them might have to do with other
symptoms that you just like to get a
little bit more information on because
sometimes an examinee might tell you
they're completely fine when you're
doing your interview with them and that
they have no symptoms and then when they
take the test it says that they're
having trouble sleeping or they struggle
with nausea all the time or they feel
very anxious and so you want to follow
up on that
okay
what's a code type
a code type
let me uh think of how to explain this
very very simply so
the main scales and i keep referring to
scales these are just uh
the main scores that come up on this
test
we
can refer to them as codes
and when i was saying that ms heard's
scores could be compared to certain
groups of people that had been
researched before to obtain similar
scores
the research has shown that certain
people will have certain scores that
kind of spike on this okay and so all of
those traits that i would describe was
describing those are traits that are
found in these code types so it means
that
number two score number two was high and
score number six was high and so if we
have those two scores were both high
then that's a two six code type and
these code types what code type was
misheard
miss heard had the clearest code type
was three six
but then she also had some other code
types that were less significant
what characteristics are associated with
a three six code type
so a three six code type
a lot of that anger is expressed in this
code type
there can be actually a lot of cruelty
usually with people who are less
powerful
actually when you see this code type you
want to if you can to follow up with
subordinates co-workers people who may
have observed their behavior more
closely
the 3-6 code type is very concerned with
their image
very attention-seeking
very prone to externalizing blame to a
point where uh
it's unclear whether they
can even admit to themselves
that they do have responsibility in
certain areas
a lot of suppressed and denied anger but
the anger is very present will explode
out and a lot of issues in their close
relationships
how does ms hurt's code type
fit in with your overall opinion as to
personality disorders
well
um
this might be an appropriate time to
describe a little bit about these
personality disorders because i think
what you'll hear is that there's a lot
of consistency there
so borderline personality disorder is a
disorder of stability it's instability
and it's instability and personal
relationships it's instability in their
emotions it's instability in their
behavior
and it's instability in their sense of
self and their identity
and
that instability is really driven by
this underlying
terror of abandonment
so
one of the key features also this
disorder and
all of it is like pistons of an engine
kind of firing off and igniting one
another
but when somebody is afraid of being
abandoned by their partner or by anybody
else in their environment and they have
this disorder
they'll make desperate attempts to
prevent that from happening
and those desperate attempts could be
physical aggression it could be
threatening it could be harming
themselves but these are behaviors that
are usually very extreme and very
concerning to the people around them
um
the anger is typically what
sadly
it's counteractive right so the thing
these people fear most is being
abandoned but over time the anger the
explosive anger that they show when
somebody is uh needing space or when
somebody's really not doing anything
wrong because a lot of times they read
into things that they perceive as being
a slight to them or being somebody
intending to harm them that actually
isn't happening they'll exaggerate it
and they'll explode they'll react in
this heightened manner
that is just exhausting for their
partners oftentimes their partners will
try to make them happy at first and
really allow themselves to be a punching
bag thinking that they can somehow solve
this problem that
somehow they can make this better and
eventually it just overwhelms them
histrionic personality disorders before
we move on okay um
are you familiar with the term
emotional reactivity i am what is that
so emotional reactivity is very common
in the diagnosis
so essentially uh like i said there's
instability and emotions people with
borderline personality disorder are
often misdiagnosed as having bipolar
disorder because they can be up and down
they can look very depressed then they
can look very elated but these changes
are happening within a matter of hours
somebody with bipolar disorder these are
this is a clinical depression lasting
days weeks a clinical mania where
sometimes they even need to be
hospitalized because they're so
grandiose they clear out their bank
account and go to vegas and spend it all
they're acting in some very bizarre ways
with uh borderline personality disorder
you're having these fluctuating moods
constantly and again this
hypersensitivity
to being slighted or feeling offended
really driven by the fear that if you're
offended or slighted if the therapist
comes in two minutes late or if somebody
shows up to dinner two minutes late that
they might be abandoning you
and it's not as if the borderline is
considering themselves abandoned in that
moment but they just know that they have
this overwhelming emotion and there are
no attempts to control that emotion
there's no there are no attempts to
regulate it so if they're in the middle
of the restaurant and they feel offended
they're going to start the fight
people are going to see it or they might
just start crying or break down but
they'll make a lot of accusations and
that reactivity is when you're gonna
just you're gonna see a lot of this
escalation the bizarre behavior they can
react violently they can react
aggressively they will often physically
prevent their partner from trying to
leave if their partner wants to get
space from all of this intense emotion
and oftentimes they will
be abusive to their partners in these
situations sometimes they'll physically
restrain them from leaving and become
injured that way but also
people with borderline personality
disorder it seems to be a predictive
factor for women who implement violence
against their partner and one of the
most common tactics that they'll use is
actually
physically assaulting and then getting
harmed themselves
but mostly
we call this administrative violence so
essentially this is saying that they'll
make threats using the
legal system so
they might say that they are going to
file a restraining order or claim abuse
or they might do these things to
essentially try to keep their partner
from leaving
in the moment again they're not
consciously thinking i'm going to keep
my partner from leaving right now
they're just thinking i can't stand this
i hate my partner they went from
idealizing to suddenly devaluing because
of the hurt and they'll do anything to
express that big emotion of anger
your honor may we approach all right yes
sir
okay
you indicated
you were talking about emotional
reactivity
uh
what
if any emotional reactivity did you
observe in your review and let's do this
one at a time
okay so there were a couple indications
to me uh
first
uh
i can sort of think about it with the
treatment records so
particularly
dr
cohen
um
am i getting the name right i feel like
for some reason in my mind i might have
just reversed it
uh but dr cohen's records i did reverse
it uh he actually refers to this
reactivity quite a bit and to misheard's
temper and that that temper it's often
branded or being hot-headed is
really characteristic of borderline
personality disorder um
as is they're very charming personable
nature it's it's this is a disorder of
contradictions
uh
in nurse philadel's notes um she had i
thought there was something interesting
she references a night when they're out
to dinner i believe in london and she
provided positive reinforcement to ms
heard because miss hurt had been
disappointed by a mistake made by the
server and it sort of references how
previously she might have criticized the
server and become upset by that
and that she didn't this time and so
that that had been some sort of a
step forward
and there was also an indication
actually in dr hughes's uh dr hughes is
a forensic psychologist who had been
appointed by ms hurd to conduct as an
evaluation as well in miss hughes's
interview of ms heard ms hurd
disclosed that she had cut her arm in
the past which is a typical reactive
type thing somebody with this diagnosis
can do it's one of the symptoms
um
and that's sort of all i can think of
top of my mind from the treatment
records
moving into
some of the declarations
or deposition testimony
what struck me was ms raquel
pennington's testimony
she's a former friend of miss herds and
she indicated she told a story about i
suppose they were shopping for
thanksgiving accoutrements something to
prepare for thanksgiving and miss her
struck her in the face
sort of out of the blue
which is
i i thought was interesting because
that is one of those
signs of borderline personality disorder
where if a if a friend or a loved one
isn't meeting your needs in that moment
borderline people with borderline
personality disorder can be very caring
in their relationships as long as their
needs are being met they feel that their
needs should be met when they want them
met
at a specific level and if they're not
then that anger that sense of harm
causes them to react so
the striking miss pennington
pennington's report in the declaration
or the testimony i thought was pretty
consistent
and then
miss herd's own self description okay
we're gonna um i'm gonna ask you a
question about um you indicated miss
pennington uh was a former friend uh yes
i've misheard
is there uh a relationship between
borderline personality disorder and uh
intimate relationships
yes so uh
so the instability definitely translates
to their relationships you'll see
relationships start very intensely
people will
somebody with borderline personality
disorder perceives the relationship as
extremely close
this pattern of idealizing and devaluing
is definitely a play they do this with
their lovers and also with their friends
and so this might be the perfect person
their perfect soul mate friend perfect
soul mate partner and their engagement
in the relationship is very alluring
very charming to the other person
and so initially everything seems great
but
what occurs is that reality sets in
people are not perfect even when we have
a lot of in common with them
whereas most of us can accept somebody
as a whole somebody who has a little bit
of flaws and still think this is my
great friend who always all constantly
running late for dinner
the person with borderline personality
disorder things are in these extremes
it's black and white we call it
splitting and so that person goes from
being idealized the perfect person to
dumpster they are totally devalued they
are the worst friend they don't care
anything about me i have better people
around and then there will be a repair
because the person with this disorder
does feel remorseful after they have
these reactions angry tell their friend
off
but over time it wears away at these
relationships and so what you'll usually
see is many
many transitions in their friendships
over the years people who have sort of
fallen by the wayside who were
really
very close-knit at one time and then but
there's not a lot of consistency in the
long term you'll also see that with
their intimate relationships
many many relationships but none that
are
particularly long term
how does borderline personality disorder
relate to identity issues
so again that instability also travels
toward identity
and when i was describing personality
earlier i was talking a little bit about
those traits we have that help us know
who we are
when you have borderline personality
disorder that actually is not something
you understand so
uh people with this disorder actually
take on the identity of the people
they're spending time with because it's
comforting it's very uncomfortable to
not know who you are some people with
this disorder will describe a feeling of
emptiness when they feel like they've
been abandoned because now they don't
know who they are in the world and so
when somebody with this disorder is
going through that initial measurement
phase with new people and they're
idealizing them they often will take on
the identities of those people so they
may mimic them in a lot of ways they
might mimic the way they dress their
interests the way they talk
um
and for this reason
the people around somebody
with this disorder kind of from the
outside may feel like
wait i thought you were this way now
you're advocating for this and this is
your new main interest in life or the
thing you're throwing yourself into all
completely music tastes might change
hobbies will change the way they dress
okay
in addition to
borderline personality disorder i
understand that you
uh
diagnosed another personality disorder
what's that
so histrionic personality disorder and
these are really two sides of the same
coin
they belong to the same cluster we call
these clusters it's a way to organize
personality disorders in that dsm and
this cluster is described as the
personality disorders that are dramatic
erratic and emotional okay so
unpredictable but really having to do
with emotions and relationships
they're very similar
whereas i was saying that borderline
personality disorder a lot of the key
features that you're going to notice are
instability
when it comes to histrionic a lot of the
key features are going to be drama
and shallowness
similarly with borderline personality
disorder there's this
under
this underlying drive of avoiding
abandonment
with histrionic personality disorder
that underlying drive is to
always be the center of attention
because if you don't have that attention
on you it feels similarly to borderline
personality disorder you feel pretty
empty like you don't have that sense of
being or of value
okay so
whereas borderline personality disorder
might have more of the visible
reactivity if somebody seems to be
leaving with histrionic personality
disorder what you're going to see is
extreme discomfort with not being the
center of attention extreme efforts to
be the center of attention
and when they feel that they're not the
center of attention
you will see some strange things
making up stories to try to get
attention often taking on a victim or
princess role those two roles in
particular are pretty consistent
seeking care taking
borderline personality disorder is
similar because
with borderline personality disorder
these shifts of identity and the
splitting you might see somebody go from
being in the dsm it describes it as a
needy supplicant of help seeking the
perfect caretaker to suddenly being the
avenger against injustice or thinking
that their partner is a terrible person
with histrionic what you'll see is
somebody who
um
wants to be the center of attention has
sort of that impressionistic speech very
flowerly
uh very enthusiastic
but nothing's really being said the
moment your attention wears away because
they're so demanding for attention
that's when they might take the victim
role or the princess role and even make
up stories sometimes those stories are
to
bolster the victim role
sometimes those stories are just to make
them look more interesting or
accomplished in their mind so that they
can get respect and attention that way
is there a relation between
histrionic personality disorder and
attractiveness attractiveness there is
strangely and this is always one of the
trickiest things
to talk about you i mean how is that a
symptom but
characteristically people with this
disorder are very very interested in
looks
but more importantly they utilize their
looks to get that attention to get that
respect that they're seeking and so this
type of a personality might be
flirtatious with everybody um
characteristically they actually
couldn't even be subtly and when i say
flirtatious i'm not talking overtly sexy
but uh kind of inappropriately
flattering sometimes they act in a kind
of a girlish way to be cute into a
gender attention and this will even
occur in their therapy relationships as
a way to sort of avoid getting negative
feedback or criticism oftentimes they'll
bring the therapist gifts or be
distracting
if they engage in therapy
because they just don't want any
criticism they want the therapist to
like them
does the intelligence of the affected
person
bear on the manner in which these
disorders present
excuse me i choked a little of my water
yes and i think one way to think about
it that's probably a little more
accurate than just intelligence is
in psychology we would describe this
more as sophistication so
street smarts so to speak um
the way
for instance i've had many clients who
have borderline personality disorder
who are
messy and really clearly suffering and
they might
be difficult and all over the place and
yell at you in the middle of session
but
it's so uh
it's not tailored it's
so much easier to work with because of
that just openness and rawness of it
genuineness
sometimes you'll have a more
sophisticated presentation there are
nine symptoms and only five have to be
met so there are a lot of different
combinations and different ways that it
can present
and sometimes you'll have more of a
petulant version of this where it really
shows when you push the button and
you're going whoa what was that so
somebody who's really productive high
functioning successful and you get to
know them and you think they're
fantastic because they're so interested
in you too and you might not realize it
but they're mimicking you perfectly so
you're really just kind of falling in
love with this new friend who is being
you
um but then all of a sudden
uh you know you say something that they
think is offensive and
you can't
e in
even in your wildest thoughts understand
how that could have offended somebody
but their reaction is so strong that you
kind of
buy into it gosh maybe i did say
something offensive and and you feel bad
about it so that sophisticated version
they can be a little bit more calculated
in the way they present they tend to
kind of hit you where it hurts a little
bit more and they can be actually very
very destructive
what conclusions were you able to draw
about miss hertz sophistication from her
testing
well from her testing and from her
presentation she's she was very likable
but her testing in particular
showed that she approached it in a
manner that
remember i told you about those those
scales that are pretty neat
um she approached it in a manner that
very clearly minimized any psychological
dysfunction
not just that but really presented
herself a free of any problems and she
did so in a way that was very um
very sophisticated not obvious
by responding to questions that most
people
might not notice
would were
trying to detect that
how did you determine that
so that's based on a particular scale on
the mmpi too that is designed
specifically to detect a type of
responding that's a little bit more
clever a little bit more sophisticated
minimizing problems in a way that most
lay people probably wouldn't unders and
even providers very difficult to detect
you mentioned that one of the
characteristics of borderline
personality disorder
is emotional reactivity
how might that present in an intimate
relationship
so
i think it probably presents mostly uh
or you'd see the bulk of it in intimate
relationships because of that regular
interaction and
the desire for your partner to meet all
of your needs to be the perfect
caretaker also that
the hallmark of the disorder with the
splitting so idealizing devaluing and
the perceiving of all sorts of neutral
events as somehow
demeaning or disrespectful
um
it's
regular
escalations of anger frustrated
complaints criticisms of your partner
but
because the person with borderline
personality disorder first of all
they're more sensitive to things
they feel distressed
more strongly and then that distress
lasts longer so these types of blow-ups
go on
forever and they're very cyclic it feels
like you just can't get a resolution and
eventually the partner will try to leave
will want to leave to take a break it
wears them down and that's when the
borderline might explode and act very
aggressively or violently to try to
prevent them from leaving
in
addition to
diagnosing misheard with
these two personality disorders
did you form another another opinion
about ms herd's mental status
yes so and not
there go ahead
if the answer to that is yes i'm gonna
now ask okay yes i did
okay what is it so uh
in addition to looking for misheard's
general mental status any psychological
issues that were present i very
specifically um was assessing to
determine whether post-traumatic stress
disorder was present and it was not how
do you know that
so first of all from uh well from
multiple information sources right so i
was integrating the interview my review
of the data the case records other
people's testimony her treatment records
and then i also conducted in addition to
the mmpi 2 and looking at that data i
also conducted
the clinician-administered ptsd scale
the caps 5 which is the gold standard
ptsd assessment
developed by the national center for
ptsd shown to be valid accurate for use
not just with service members but also
with civilians
men women all genders
and also
all ethnicities and then also
specifically for use in a courtroom
setting
how do you conduct the caps five
so the caps five is a standard interview
what that means is that it's an
interview with very clear questions that
are scripted
and you ask those same questions
every time you test a person so because
you're doing that you're actually taking
something that would typically be kind
of subjective an interview with somebody
and you're making it more objective when
you ask those same questions in the same
way
every time somebody's assessed with this
now you can apply a scoring protocol and
actually score their responses
okay
as a result of applying those protocols
what did you conclude
miss heard did not have ptsd
and there were also
pretty significant indications that she
was grossly exaggerating symptoms of
ptsd when asked about them how did you
make that latter conclusion
so
one of the strengths of this test as i
mentioned
the important thing about any test used
when you're doing an evaluation in
forensics is to make sure that the
person is responding accurately
and this test does that by not just
asking people whether they have a
symptom
but asking follow-up questions that draw
out very detailed accounts of every
single symptom of ptsd
and when you're really familiar with
this disorder which you need to be to
administer this test
there are nuances in the way a person
will describe their symptoms that have
been shown repeatedly to indicate
exaggeration or faking there are also
indications
when somebody is clearly giving you a
genuine response
okay
what
if any symptoms of ptsd did you observe
and misheard
so
there are 20 kind of core symptoms that
somebody might
can manifest with ptsd you don't have to
have all of them
ms hurt initially said that she had in
the first question you say do you ever
have this before you get to the more
nuanced follow-up questions when i ask
that first question on each item she
initially said yes i have that to 19 of
the 20 symptoms
that's not typical even of somebody with
the most disabling form of ptsd
when we eventually sort of dialed it
down she had three remaining symptoms
and having symptoms of any disorder is
common for all of us some of us struggle
with sleep some of us get anxious
it could be several different disorders
it could just be that you have this
struggle in your life
but she had three specific symptoms that
i scored as present
off the top of my head i might miss one
but one was sleep disturbance so um
she reported that she has frequent
nightmares
another one was that she said that she
tends to have a startle response so if
she gets startled or surprised
she tends to stay in sort of a hyper
startle
mode for quite a while and that's
consistent with a couple of things it
can be consistent with ptsd if other
criteria are met
it's also consistent with childhood
complex trauma which is something that
can occur when your brain is forming if
you constantly feel unsafe if your
parents are abusive
or if they're not present if you're
neglected
you can develop
certain physiological responses that can
stay for a long time in your life
so
i i noted that that would seem like a
very genuine accurate account where she
stays in the state of kind of hyper
arousal has a hard time calming down if
she gets surprised
you mentioned nightmares as well yes did
she recount for you the nature of the
nightmares
so they were vague uh
she indicated
that uh she has recurrent nightmares and
that she feels as though she's being
held down
um
and there there was some conflict in
that account because
even though that could be a ptsd symptom
it is it is fairly vague but i still
scored it as present
and in her
initial treatment with miss
i'm sorry with dr bonnie jacobs
which i believe started before she began
dating mr deb
she had indicated
to dr jacobs according to dr jacobs's
notes that she was having repetitive
nightmares back then and that they were
related to her childhood trauma
and so that came up several times in the
notes dr jacobs kept mentioning that
thank you
what is feigning
feigning is
essentially faking or exaggerating uh
symptoms that aren't present
does the caps 5 control for that
it doesn't necessarily control for it it
can expose it by drawing out how does
that work because you're not just simply
handing the person a checklist that says
here are all the symptoms of ptsd why
don't just check off the ones you have
which clearly if you're trying to look
like you have ptsd you would just check
them all
the caps 5 because it requires them to
describe in detail
how they experience the symptom where it
shows up what it looks like what sort of
examples they can give you how many
times it's happened in the last couple
weeks how many times it's happened in
the last month
by the end of each symptom you've gotten
a very good picture of a couple things
one does it meet the definition of the
symptom are they getting it right right
is this actually the symptom are they
kind of confusing this was something
else
number two
are they giving you very vague accounts
um are they giving you kind of a
stereotyped idea of what the symptom is
based on media or movies or something
that actually is completely different
from genuine experiences of this symptom
or are they giving you
a very genuine heartfelt sometimes
minimizing
but it's it's taking all the boxes their
mannerisms while they're describing it
the uh actual very specific very nuanced
symbolic ways they're describing it a
lot of times
it's smells it sounds that all appears
in genuine accounts and it's something
that people really get wrong when
they're feigning
all right
in addition to your conclusion that
ms heard does not have ptsd did you make
a conclusion with respect
to her symptoms
uh yes actually i did so
uh you know just because somebody
doesn't have ptsd doesn't mean that they
weren't harmed psychologically by
whatever is being alleged in this case
ms heard is alleging that she was
psychologically harmed in that she
suffered ptsd because of abuse that she
alleges occurred by mr deb
so i also
the mmpi too is helpful because it shows
you kind of everything any other
symptoms and then in ms herd's own
self-report and her prior treatment
records i knew that she had
reported to me that
she had had some other symptoms so now
what becomes really important
is determining
and let me clarify one thing here not so
much a diagnosis
but did she start to experience symptoms
during the relationship and after did
they worsen after
or
could these types of symptoms or reports
be explained by other factors a bypaning
b by pre-existing conditions or c by
other stressful life events that might
have occurred
so the main
symptoms that i was looking at didn't
meet criteria for ptsd right there was
also um you know substantial evidence of
this sort of emotional dysregulation
emotional disorganization the
shallowness the dramatic affect
now when you have a lot of childhood
trauma you can actually have
some similar type presentation in
adulthood there are some differences
though but also
that's not something that would have
occurred after this relationship so now
i was looking at are there indications
that these types of things that she's
described
this transient anxiety the issues with
sleep were these there prior
and sure enough
miss heard in her own self-report stated
to me that when she first got to la she
was seeking treatment for in her words
blanket anxiety and depression
she also reported that she was taking
medications in general none of them were
helpful that's actually very typical of
borderline personality disorder
medications typically aren't very
helpful for somebody with a disorder
they really need an intensive lifelong
type of therapy which is not necessarily
as relevant to this
but interestingly also
people with borderline personality
disorder often respond really positively
to
stimulant medications that are uh given
for add or adhd and in one of nurse
fellotti's notes she reported that ms
heard told her that none of the
medications were working for her except
for one provisional which is often
prescribed it's a stimulant medication
and i just thought that was interesting
and sort of consistent with more of
these lifelong personality disorders
that aren't necessarily caused by a harm
by any allegations but have been there
and will remain there typically
the other uh issue you know
so the anxiety she had already indicated
that it that had been there prior but
the form of the anxiety so looking at dr
hughes's testing and then also looking
at the scores on the mmpi when you look
at all these little combinations of the
scores you can actually learn a lot
about is the anxiety related to an event
or is this more a person who tends to be
an anxious person regardless of what's
going on in their life and somebody
might describe them as a worrywart and
the scores the little
combination of scores that she obtained
actually indicated that it was the
latter that her anxiety tends to be
separate from events and more just kind
of a constant and it comes and goes but
it's more of a trait
i have no further questions for this
witness all
right maybe we why don't we go ahead and
um go ahead and have our lunch break it
might be a good idea to to break it up
there
okay i know i could see you jumping up
all right uh ladies and gentlemen let's
go ahead and take our lunch recess just
again do not do any outside research and
don't discuss the case with anybody okay
we'll have you back here
okay
and again doctor curious you're in the
middle of your testimony please do not
discuss your testimony with anybody at
this time okay
all right let's just when we come back
at 150 okay come back 150 all right
thank you
foreign
okay
you have your seats all right cross
examination you can sit down
thank you
dr curry you're not board certified
correct no i'm not not in clinical
psychology or in forensic psychology
correct no i'm a licensed clinical
psychologist but you're not board
certified no okay and you also have only
been practicing approximately eight
years is that correct that's not correct
how many years
i've been licensed for ten years okay
and i've been practicing for about 15
years okay and that includes what you
went through with your different trials
in hawaii and everything else that you
testified to correct yes okay
now
you went to mr depp's home
for dinner and drinks
before you were hired as an expert in
this case correct that's not quite what
right i was interviewed at mr depp's
home by his legal team dinner was served
you in attendance with mr depp was adam
waldman correct yes ben chu
correct yes camille vasquez yes okay and
the dinner lasted approximately three to
four hours correct yes and it includes
the interviews correct
yes dinner and i believe drinks were
served okay
and this was before you were hired as an
expert correct
yes this was an interview so that they
could make an informed decision as to
whether or not to retain me
and don't you think that's a little odd
that you're getting interviewed by mr
depp
to decide whether you're going to
testify adversely against amber heard
i was interviewed by the legal team
and mr depp was present it was his home
correct yes and he was serving dinner
and drinks he was not serving dinner
it was at his house at his behest
correct yes it was at his house okay and
you were contacted by camille vasquez
somebody you knew in the community in
february of 2020 is that correct
i knew of ms vasquez professionally we
live in the same city and i work with
many attorneys okay
and at that time you not only knew
johnny depp you'd seen a number of his
tv and movie roles and you believed he
was a good actor correct
not correct i did not know johnny depp
i had seen several of his movies you
knew who he was yes right and you
believed he was a good actor yes okay
and then
you provided an expert designation in
this case before ever seeing amber or
having an opportunity to review any
documents or records isn't that correct
i did not provide an expert designation
that's that's an attorney thing
my opinions are contained in my report
plaintiff's exhibit 884 please
this was plaintiff's designation
identification of expert witnesses in
this case
and this is dated february 2021. that's
a year after you went to dinner at mr
depp's house correct yes okay
and it attributes if you go to page 13
it says you have three opinions
the first of those is that amber heard
quote
exhibits patterns of behavior that are
consistent with co-occurring cluster b
personality disorder traits especially
borderline personality disorder did i
get that right
i'm reading that here that is not my
opinion okay well but it's a current
opinion but this was not an opinion of
mine then i didn't have any opinions at
that time it says dr curry will testify
correct that's what it says yes okay and
this is a signed pleading correct on
behalf of mr death i i'm not sure i
understand what that means
we don't understand what a signed
pleading is no okay do you understand
that mr depp's counsel prepared this and
served it on ms heard's counsel
i i'm not an attorney i don't understand
necessarily all of these procedures okay
are you aware that mr depp is on an
audio recording years earlier taunting
amber heard that she has a borderline
personality disorder i was made aware of
that in this case yes so you did
actually
not necessarily taunting but i do recall
hearing that mr depp had used that
phrase so it's a coincidence that you
now think she has those attributes after
the attorneys listed it in february 2021
before you looked at anything and
mr depp had made that accusation to ms
heard years earlier my opinions aren't
based on coincidences
objection i'm sorry doctor yes
compound i'll sustain the objection all
right it's a coincidence then that you
came up with symptoms of borderline
personality disorder
years later after mr depp has been
taunting this heard in an audio tape
i can't speak to whether or not there's
a coincidence but i can tell you is my
opinions are based on the results of my
evaluation and it's a coincidence that
mr depp's council attributed that to you
that said
that to you in february 2021 before you
looked at anything correct
i'm not sure okay now would you agree
that a disproportionate
number of women
are tagged with a diagnosis of
borderline personality disorder
no that's not quite right
75
the way you phrase it is not quite right
tell me tell me what's right okay so
there are more women
who have been diagnosed with bipolar
disorder than men it's more prevalent in
women
and trauma can cause borderline
personality disorders can't it no
never
right now we know that there are people
who have borderline personality disorder
who have sustained childhood trauma
there are also people who have
borderline personality disorder who have
had no childhood trauma so
like most personality disorders and
really like most mental health issues in
general there seems to be both a
biological component in this case with
borderline personality disorder the
research tends to support a genetic
component and possibly a neurological
component and then there is also
possibly an environmental component
triggering those genetic markers do you
know the percentage of women who are
victims of ipv intimate partner violence
or domestic abuse who are diagnosed with
borderline personality disorders i can't
tell you the percentage off at the top
of my head but i do know that there is a
larger
women with borderline personality
disorder tend to
have a higher prevalence of being
involved in intimate partner violence
relationships being the receiver of
violence and being the perpetuators of
violence now you've never been asked to
testify or serve as an expert with
respect to whether someone has a bipolar
disorder is that correct a bipolar
disorder yes that's not correct okay
bear with me
yes we are
thank you
thank you
taken in this case
yes on march 21 2022 i believe that was
the date yes and were you under oath at
that time yes all right i'm going to ask
you to turn to
page 207
and the question was have you ever been
asked to testify or serve as an expert
with respect to whether someone has
bipolar disorder and your answer at that
time will you please read to the jury
i'm sorry page 207 207 line five ah
could you no
okay thank you
now
when this designation was served in
february of 2021 you had not rendered an
opinion that quote ms heard exhibits
patterns of behavior that are consistent
with co-occurring cluster cluster b
personality disorder traits especially
borderline personality disorder correct
i'm sorry i
i missed the first part what was that
when this designation was served that
you have in front of you as plaintiff's
exhibit 884
you had not rendered
an opinion that quote misheard exhibits
patterns of behavior that are consistent
with co-occurring cluster b personality
disorder traits especially borderline
personality disorder correct no i had
not rendered any opinions my opinions
weren't finalized until after my
evaluation right so when this came out
you had not rendered that opinion i had
not rendered that opinion okay the
second opinion that's listed in the
february 2021
is that
ms heard repeatedly and
characterologically
perpetuated severe physical and
psychological intimate partner violence
ipv toward mr depp over the course of
their relationship end of quote did i
read that correctly
uh it says perpetrated but other than
that yes okay and so it is it correct
that they that
this pleading says in february 2021 that
you are going to testify to that
this document
yes okay it says that and you have never
been asked to testify as to whether
anyone has behaviorally or
characterologically conducted conduct
that suggests they may be an ipv
perpetrator correct
i have i have to ask that again because
i stumbled i can't do character
logically that one's just a tough one
for me okay
you have never been asked to testify as
to whether anyone has behavioral or
character logical conduct that suggests
they may have been an ipv perpetrator
correct no i've never been asked to
testify for that okay
and that was not your opinion in
february 2021 correct no
and in fact you do not hold that opinion
now and you were not even asked to
provide such an analysis or opinion
isn't that correct no or that is correct
that's correct okay
and you have never held that opinion
correct
no that is correct yes okay
in your third opinion if we can go to
page 14.
was that ms heard exhibits patterns of
behavior that suggest her allegations of
abuse against mr depp are false end of
quote do you see that
i see that you said it's my third
opinion that is not my opinion
all right but in this pleading it says
that you will testify to that correct
yes that's what this says okay and that
was not your opinion in february 2021
was it
no as i said
i had not formed any opinions at that
time i had just been retained
and in fact you have never arrived at
this opinion as an expert witness in
this case correct
in terms of the opinions that i've
rendered are provided in my report
and they're what i'm testifying to today
and you have never arrived at this
opinion as an expert witness in this
case correct objection
you have never arrived at the opinion
that ms heard exhibits patterns of
behavior that suggest her allegations of
abuse against mr deb are false correct
that's correct okay and in fact you've
said that has never been my opinion
correct
what i'm saying is that this the
opinions in here i these are not my
opinions my opinions are provided in my
report can you please turn to page 255
of your deposition
and if we can start on 254 to give i
don't have that page i'm sorry 254 line
11. oh okay
and the question is now the next one is
quote ms heard exhibits patterns of
behavior that suggest her allegations of
abuse against mr deb are false end of
quote was that your opinion in february
2021 and you answered at that time no
correct
that is correct and then i asked have
you ever arrived at that opinion in the
time that you have served as an expert
witness in this case
and your answer was could you read that
to the jury please yes um so no it's not
the task
i was cut off or i
essentially what i wrote i what i said
then was
not the task of dash that was never my
task to determine can i say what that
means
no and then the question is so is it
fair to say
that you have never arrived at an
opinion that quote ms heard exhibits
patterns of behavior that suggest
allegations of abuse against mr depp are
false end of quote and what was your
answer
well there is an objection all right
i'll i'll i'll read it for you if you're
having difficulty your answer was under
oath correct that is not my opinion that
has never been my opinion
isn't that what i said on growth on
march 21st
okay
and then i wrote do you then i'm going
to ask you do you know who wrote this
portion of the designation suggesting
that these were your opinions in
february of 2021
and what was your answer i said no
now
as of the time of this initial expert
designation you had not reviewed any
materials reached any opinions correct
i believe i just started to review
materials um i i believe that i
indicated that in my deposition i had
not yet rendered any opinions
i
[Music]
hadn't completed my review and i hadn't
conducted an evaluation okay and in fact
you've never testified as an expert on
ipv intimate partner violence isn't that
correct
i believe that is correct but i may not
be remembering all of my cases so let's
go to page 200 okay
line 17
my question was have you ever testified
as an expert on ipv
and your answer under oath then at line
22 was what
oh gosh let me catch up line 22
no and you've never testified as an
expert on emotional distress damages
associated with ipv is that correct
that's correct okay and you've never
been asked to testify with respect to
emotional damages associated with
domestic violence or abuse isn't that
correct
uh again that
i'm reluctant to say that's correct
because
with 15 years of experiences i'll
experience a lot of my cases have been
complex and that may have been a
component but i don't
remember explicitly a case being just
about that let's go to page 199 line 20.
my question to you was have you ever
been asked to testify with respect to
emotional damages associated with
domestic violence or abuse
and your answer under oath at that time
was
no
i've not right sorry i just hadn't been
on the page in time okay you said no
i've not but i have not okay
now you also have never been asked to
testify on whether an individual is
being truthful in saying that they are a
survivor of ipv is that correct
that's correct okay and you have never
qualified as an expert to speak to
whether a person suffered from ipv
intimate partner violence or was a
victim or survivor of ipv is that
correct that's outside the task of a
psychologist
to determine whether an event occurred
we assess behavior we have we assess
mental status we don't
detect crimes
so you have not been asked to testify to
that correct it's not something that
occurs so no i have not and you were not
ultimately asked to provide any opinions
on that correct no i was not okay
now you did not disclose in any of the
designations or your report
that you had met with and had dinner and
drinks with mr depp did you
i'm sorry can you repeat that one more
time you did not disclose in any of the
designations or in your report
then you had dinner and drinks with mr
deck correct i did not disclose that i
was interviewed by the legal team no
i asked a different question
are you trying to resist that you didn't
have dinner with mr depp and drinks i'm
not trying to resist that but it's not
quite right
you didn't have dinner with mr deb did
you not i did with you
did you not
and what you had drinks with mr depp did
you know drinks were served i this was
over two years ago i may have had a
drink with dinner yes
in fact you thought you had a mule
something right
possibly yes okay and you didn't
disclose that you had met with mr dap mr
waldman mr chu and ms vasquez at mr
depp's house for three to four hours and
had dinner and drinks correct i did not
disclose that it's not significant to
the report
you don't think that's significant
correct i don't okay but you've never
been asked to meet with a client in his
council before being retained as an
expert either before or after have you
no
and you justified that it was okay in
this case because it was a high profile
case that's not quite right i justified
it in this case actually i sought
consultation about it first of all
the person who had retained his
attorneys was unable to come to my
office with his attorneys and yes this
is a very visible case it's been going
on a very long time and i understood
that there would be a need to
interview me and determine make an
informed decision about my
qualifications
can you look at page 240 please
line three is my question would you
agree it's a highly irregular to me with
the subject in a litigation
and your answer on that occasion was i
would not say it's highly irregular i
would say it's not something that i
would typically do however i had not yet
been retained on the case this was a
large high profile case and i understood
that i believed that it was appropriate
for a person retaining me with such a
high profile to meet me to be able to
vet me essentially with the attorneys
present prior to retaining me on his
case do you recall that yes that's what
you said under oath correct and then i
said have you ever done that before and
you said no
correct and then i said have you ever
done it since and you said no correct
correct okay
now
would you agree
that
if you
did not find
something that would be
in favor of mr depp and
negative to ms heard that you wouldn't
be an expert in this case
essentially into court if you're going
to say
that heard is right mr depp is wrong so
as a forensic psychologist my obligation
is to the court is to the fact finder
i
present science regardless of what that
science may be
now when i take a case my retainer
agreement is explicit about that and i
just discussed that i'm just asking you
i'm asking you a question i'd like you
to try to answer okay question you
understand that if you found favorably
to misheard and negatively to mr depp
you wouldn't be here right you wouldn't
be testifying
objection
no i
okay sorry hold on
the objection of speculation
that's that's not speculation no i'll
sustain the objection if you want to ask
okay
if
it goes to bias your honor i sustain the
objection next question okay all right
you were in fact so excited about being
involved in this case that you told your
husband even though this was a highly
confidential matter that you were going
to be conducting the examination of ms
heard didn't you that is not accurate
you not only told your husband but you
told miss heard that you told your
husband correct
ms bretoff that is not accurate what is
accurate
you're incorrect that is not correct
is your testimony today under oath that
you did not tell your husband that you
were going to be conducting the
examination of amber that is my
testimony
okay
let's go to page 306.
so the question that was asked was
because you brought muffins you said
from your husband right you get and you
gave those to ms heard correct
may i clarify what occurred so that we
can stop talking about the muffins
what happened was that
i was getting ready that morning i
frequently bring muffins to the office
my husband did happen to know that there
was going to be a celebrity client
coming in because on the mornings that
that occurs which
often occurs we have to actually clear
the office and move the staff to the
other office so yes
on the one hand he was aware that i was
getting ready i asked him to go to the
bakery near our house and pick up the
muffins for me because i was running
late he often has to do that because i
often do run late he brought the muffins
back to the house i brought them into
the office
ms heard and i enjoyed the muffins
together i think i made a comment to her
along the lines like we can thank my
husband he brought her my husband got
these for us today meaning he purchased
the muffins we are now enjoying them
because of him
did you say on pages 305 and 306 that
you frequently have examinations of
high-profile clients
you want to just take a quick look and
tell us
what
306 yeah that's where we're talking
about it is there a line you'd like me
to look at you can start with
uh
15
line 15 305. just read through that and
tell me whether you said anywhere in
there that you have a lot of high
profile examinations you do this
frequently
i i don't agree don't you approach
please
so
why did your husband get the muffins for
amber heard
he did not get the muffins for amber
heard
he knew you had a high profile client
and he was and you were preparing for a
very long time and you asked him to pick
up the muffins correct i asked him to
pick up the muffins for me yes okay
now would you agree that domestic abuse
can be verbal
absolutely yes would you agree that
domestic abuse can be emotional
yes certainly would you agree that
domestic abuse can be psychological
yes would you agree that domestic abuse
can be physical yes okay now you
indicated i believe you testified in
your direct that it's very important to
review the treatment records before
forming opinions is that correct yes
okay in fact that's the first thing you
would do correct
not necessarily the first but it's part
of the evaluation
let's go to page 261.
and let's go to 260 because that's where
i start the question
the question i asked was and do you
recall whether you'd review any of these
by the designation on february 19 2021
and you said okay i can't say for
certain what i can tell you is that
knowing my normal procedure i would have
reviewed the treatment records first did
you testify to that under oath then yes
okay
now before we start getting into the
ones that you testified about i just
want to be really clear about what
you actually
have as an opinion with respect to the
borderline personality disorder and the
histrionics
you didn't diagnose you didn't
actually have a dsm 5 diagnosis that
amber heard suffers from either
borderline personality disorder or
histrionic personality disorder correct
that's not correct
your in fact your report
says ms heard demonstrates
psychological symptoms
of a combined borderline and histrionic
personality disorder would you agree
yes i did say that in also what
designation was that i believe january
18th that report was included
yes okay and that's what you said at
that time correct yes okay
i said a little bit more than that as
well
you said
and i'll read it i'll quote it
quote based on the combined results of
my interview with ms heard behavioral
observations
psychometric test data and review of the
available records ms heard demonstrates
psychological symptoms
of a combined borderline and histrionic
personality disorder bhpd that's what
you wrote in your report as one of your
conclusions and that's a dsm 5 diagnosis
and it did not say that you were
diagnosing with a dsm
for borderline personality disorder or
histrionic personality disorder did it
that's what it says in different
semantics
oh so so so what you meant to do it did
not use the words you just said
now let's talk about the treatment
records that you said that you reviewed
but i'm going to start with rocky
pennington
your testimony was that out of the blue
amber hit rocky pennington correct
i can't remember exactly what i said but
i did reference miss pennington's
deposition that ms heard struck miss
pennington in the face in fact ms
pennington testified that she hit ms
heard
and in response to that she can't recall
but ms heard either pushed or slapped
her correct
i don't recall
that's a pretty important distinction
don't you think
my recollection is that there was some
sort of violence both ways in the
relationship either way it seemed that
both of them might have been unstable
i'm only evaluating miss hurt so so now
we have an evaluation of rocky
pennington no i just said but that was
not relevant to my opinion because i'm
only evaluating this heart but you
testified to that on direct that that
was a factor right yes okay well
wouldn't it make a big difference if
amber struck first or just responded
back
given the dynamic not necessarily no it
would not have so so now you're an
expert on rocky pennington and her
dynamics with amber hurt
okay so now let's talk about dr cowan
you not only reviewed his treatment
records and his text messages and
documents but you also attended his
deposition did you not
yes okay
and do you recall dr cowan testifying
that amber told him about depp
physically abusing her contemporaneous
with the events
i don't recall specifically his words
but i
remember him recalling that she had
disclosed abuse in their treatment yes
and do you recall dr cowan testifying
that he received a text message
contemporaneous
that johnny did a number on me tonight
i'm safe in my support tonight but i
need some real help do you remember him
testifying to that i don't remember the
testimony but i do remember seeing that
text message as one of the exhibits and
do you remember dr cowan testifying that
on another occasion amber sent them a
text johnny beat me up pretty good last
night end of quote again
not in this constant she she's can rely
on it and she's
overruled thank you thank you i didn't
need to argue that hard i guess do you
recall that
again i don't recall the testimony but i
do remember that being an exhibit i've
seen it do you recall dr cowan
testifying that not only did he believe
amber in her reporting of the abuse by
depp but that she had no ulterior motive
i actually don't recall that i'm not
saying that it didn't occur okay
do you recall dr cowan testifying that
he believed the relationship was toxic
and he was concerned for amber's
physical well-being
i do recall him saying that he believed
the relationship was toxic
and you don't recall i don't know how
insane that he was concerned for amber's
physical well-being i don't remember
those exact words
do you believe do you recall dr cowan
testifying in that deposition that you
were present for referring to mr depp
quote his controlling nature jealousy
and suspiciousness addiction to drugs
and alcohol and violent and indulgent
temper do you recall him using those
terms to describe mr depp i remember
thinking that would be an inappropriate
impression for a treating provider of a
different person to give
um but i do recall him making that
statement
do you recall dr cohen testifying that
if he pushed her she was going to push
him back and i never had the impression
that she was the provocateur but that
she was indicating to me she had a hard
time you know de-escalating these types
of situations
yes okay and do you also recall him
saying that she didn't say she pushed
him she just said i got right back up he
told me that she told me that he pushed
her down and she got back right back up
i remember him saying that miss heard
told him that yes and do you recall him
testifying you could interpret it that
way i kind of interpret it more you know
metaphorically that when somebody comes
at her she goes back at them you know in
a similar way whether it's verbally or
she protects herself
i i may i recall something along those
lines but it was a six or seven hour
deposition so the specifics are not
fresh in my mind do you recall dr cowan
specifically testifying that he believed
amber heard when she reported the
physical abuse by mr depp i recall him
saying that and following it up with a
statement that you have to take the
patient at their word when you're the
therapist
you recall that yes
do you recall him saying he took her
that he believed her that he found her
believers yes yes that he found her
believable okay um now you also testify
about amy banks do you recall that yes
and before we go there dr cohen has been
a clinical psychologist for 40 years
correct
i'm not sure okay well he testified to
that didn't he in the deposition i don't
recall and he also saw amber heard for
over two years correct
yes from 2014 approximately august 2014
to
2000 through 2016 correct yes
for a period of time would you agree
okay and he also testified that he did
not diagnose amber with borderline
personality disorder do you recall that
testimony he also testified that he
doesn't use diagnoses but yes i do
recall that and do you recall that it
was in those words were in his notes
but he said he had written that down but
then he discounted it and determined
that that was not correct for her
don't you approach
all right now let's jump to amy banks
dr banks is a psychiatrist correct
correct yes in fact she went to medical
school georgetown and she did her
psychiatric training at harvard medical
school correct i believe that's correct
i don't recall 100
all right and she
was a psychiatrist in massachusetts that
amber heard had reached out to yes after
the australia incident to try to help
her relationship with mr depp correct
let me back up you attended dr banks
deposition as well did you not yes i did
and dr banks testified to that correct
uh i don't remember if she testified to
that i don't have the notes right in
front of me or the deposition transcript
all right
do you recall dr banks testifying
that
she understood
that amber was in a relationship with
johnny depp that had gotten violent and
out of control
i
i don't recall specifically no
do you recall amy banks testifying that
they had physical altercations and his
drug use had escalated and amber felt
she was at risk
i don't recall
do you recall amy banks testifying that
amber was reporting the violence by mr
depp and it was not consensual
i recall dr banks stating that ms heard
was reporting violence to her yes i do
not recall a statement about
consent
do you recall
dr banks testifying
that
there was discussion about mr depp
cutting off his finger and she said only
that it was a middle of one of these
very kind of out of control escalated
fights and that did make a fairly big
impact on me
i remember something like that
all right and do you recall that dr
banks saying it was a whole other level
as i remember it told to me he actually
cut off a part of his finger during one
of these altercations meaning to me the
way i digested that if you will was that
things had gotten particularly out of
control
i do not recall that exact statement i'm
not saying it didn't occur i just can't
recall it right and
you recall that mr depp was in sessions
with ms heard with dr banks correct
i yes
my understanding however is that they
met with dr banks and then it was
primarily misheard meeting with dr banks
for treatment after prescriptions and
therapy all right and do you recall dr
banks saying that she was not surprised
that amber was seeking a restraining
order because of the violence that she
knew existed in the relationship
i do recall that and it would be
impossible to know that violence exists
as a treating therapist or as a
psychologist again we're not
investigators however i do recall that
she said that because i remember having
that thought
and do you recall amy and she's a
psychiatrist right psychiatrist
and do you recall amy banks saying that
it was clear to her that mr depp was the
one who initiated the violence i don't
recall that
all right
do you recall
that dr banks said
that she knew for certain
that mr depp was the one who who had
committed the violence because ms heard
reported it in the presence of mr depp
and he did not contradict i do not
recall that okay
and do you recall that dr banks
ultimately concluded that it was her
belief that amber was a victim of
domestic violence at the hands of mr
debt
here you want to approach this
and what was your answer to that last
one i'm sorry
i
i think i can't recall but i also can't
recall that last question do you recall
that dr banks concluded that amber was a
victim of domestic violence at the hands
of mr depp
i don't recall that
okay
now
you also reviewed the records of laurel
anderson and you reviewed her deposition
is that correct
um let me refresh my memory for a moment
ah
i reviewed uh dr anderson's deposition
yes okay and do you recall that she
reported that that amber heard had had
reported physical violence by mr depp to
her i recall that she said that ms heard
had reported that yes okay and do you
recall that she said that it changed
over time
i don't recall that specifically okay
and do you recall dr anderson saying
that she had witnessed her face being
bruised after the december 15 2015
incident i don't recall that you don't
recall that okay
um
and do you recall
that dr anderson said that amber had
reported that
uh he had pulled out her hair bruised
her face kicked her leg and hit her in
the head
yes miss her did report that to her
according to her testimony okay
and do you recall that amber heard said
that mr deb was scaring her
i don't recall that specifically okay
and do you recall that dr anderson said
she believed that amber heard was a
victim of domestic abuse at the hands of
mr dell
i recall uh no i don't recall that
statement
all right let's go to bonnie jacobs
you said that you reviewed the notes
from bonnie jacobs correct
yes
and what you testified to
was that you discounted these because
the first notes from
bonnie jacobs indicated that she already
had all of these symptoms correct
just i'm sorry i don't understand what
you're saying i just counted
tell me why you discounted bonnie jacobs
notes
i did not discount bonnie jacobs notes
you said that she the bonnie jacobs in
her notes had already
determined that these symptoms were
present for amber heard before the
relationship with mr depp did you not
what i recall saying
was that
within
dr jacobs's notes
she's documented instances in which ms
heard reported to her over the course of
therapy that she was experiencing
nightmares recurrent nightmares in fact
about childhood abuse
okay now the very first
entry on bonnie jacobs notes and these
are the notes right do you recognize
these i do and we received more uh sort
of at the tail end just a couple months
ago all right so the first of bonnie
jacobs notes is on 1017 2011. do you
recall that i i don't recall the exact
date i don't have anything in front of
me and she was already amber heard was
already in the relationship with johnny
depp at this point was she not
i believe she was yes okay and in bonnie
jacobs notes she
documents however oh go ahead she
documents multiple
multiple occasions that amber heard
reports to her
physical violence
upon her by mr depp does she not
there are several notes that indicate
that ms hurt has reported violence by mr
depp yes many many correct
i wouldn't qualify it as many many
i'm not sure what you mean by honeymoon
how many would you say i don't know i
don't have the notes in front of me okay
well what do you recall in deciding to
make your opinions in this case well i'm
confused about the dates because i know
that dr jacobs treated miss hurt even
while she was in her prior relationship
leaving her prior relationship with her
last wife dr curry i'm not going to ask
you to try to bring in extraneous things
i'm asking you what you recall of these
but the dates would have been different
based on that alone okay and i recall
that there was quite a bit of
information because these were copious
notes spanning back in time from her
relationship with tasha dr dr curry
please answer my question how many
occasions do you recall
dr
i don't know dr jacobs documenting amber
reporting physical abuse i don't know
now you also said that you listened to
audio tapes in this case correct
yes did you hear mr depp admitting to
head-butting ms heard
that is not what i heard you didn't hear
that i heard a conversation about head
butting i did not hear him as you said
admit to head butting misheard okay
that's your characterization of it
correct yes okay
um
did you see the videotape of mr depp in
the kitchen yes okay did ms heard
imagine that or create that or was she
responsible for that somehow
i'll sustain your checks next question
okay um
what if any impact did you have did that
have on your opinions watching mr depp
in that video
i'm not sure
it was one of many
pieces of the exhibits and other
collateral data that i considered i'm
not sure what the direct impact was or
if that could be measured all right now
council asked you whether you had
conducted any type of examination on mr
depp and i believe your answer was no
correct
no you did not review any medical
records or psychological records from mr
depp either did you
i reviewed all of the records that were
available do you recall reviewing
medical and psychological recognition
yes do you recall dr blaustein referring
to mr depp having rage
no i actually recall him referring to
miss hurd in that note
your testimony is that dr blaustein
was referring to amber heard as having
rage
i transcribed several of the notes and i
may be missing a time when he
i said that about mr depp the
handwriting was very difficult to
transcribe but there was one
instance in which i recall transcribing
him
stating that mr depp reported that ms
heard had rage
dr blaustein's deposition was taken was
it not
uh i
don't recall do you recall as i take it
then you don't recall him testifying
that mr depp told him he had rage and
demons i don't recall
do you recall dr blaustein testifying
that mr depp
looked at his wife amber like his mother
or his sister that he didn't like
i haven't seen his deposition i don't
recall that okay
now did you see and do you know whether
mr depp has ever been diagnosed with any
personality disorders
my that's not relevant to my task to
conduct an evaluation of ms heard so
i do not know that he has had one it was
not in the records that he did all right
so one way or the other you don't know
whether mr depp suffers from any
personality disorders
there was
that's not my task okay let me go to
ipv
perpetrators would you agree
that accusations of infidelity can be
considered one of the characteristics of
a personality perpetrator of ipv
it can be a characteristic of a lot of
things it is something that can be
weaponized if somebody is trying to or
is having rage toward their partner
let's go to page 270.
line three my question was are
accusations of infidelity considered one
of the characteristics of a perpetrator
a personality perpetrator of ipv
the objection
um
the question is
is vague and ultimately ambiguous
i i don't understand the objection all
over all the objections okay and your
answer under can you remind me of the
page page 270.
line three was where my question was
okay and your answer is at line eight
you said it can be correct yes okay
and
interrogating your partner about
unfounded accusations of infidelity can
be abusive would you agree
it can be if they're unfounded yes okay
and
psychological consequences for a victim
of ipv
can include diminished self-esteem
correct yes depressed mood yes anxiety
yes fearfulness
certainly diminished self-agency
yes feeling powerless
yes loss of sleep
yes
and ipv is a traumatic stressor would
you agree it is right and ipv is capable
of resulting in ptsd is it not it is
okay and ipv is capable of resulting in
other trauma-based disorders correct
yes okay
now
amber's medical examination she was
cooperative correct
her psychological yes she was
cooperative and polite okay and and in
the two full days of examination you
felt she was polite and answered all
your questions
except in one instance where she
furrowed her brow when you were asking
about friendships in high school correct
that's not correct
all right let's go to page 275.
so we start on 274 with the was she
polite you said yes was she cooperative
yes um did she answer your questions for
the most part yes this is uh now we're
on page 275 lines four and five and then
my question was did she at any time
become combat combative or unfriendly
with you or angry
and your answer was there was one
instance in which she appeared annoyed
and the posturing forward a bit more
assertive tone furrowed brow when i was
questioning something following up on
data that had been inconsistent about
friendships in high school other than
that she was very polite is that your
answer at that time
that was my answer at that time and it's
inconsistent with the question you had
just asked me
and would you agree that appearing for
this examination with an expert who had
been retained by mr depp
more than a year earlier might be a
little stressful
yes okay
and in fact not only had you been
retained by mr depp but what had been
communicated by mr depp's team was that
you had called amber heard a liar and a
perpetrator of abuse correct first of
all i i'd like to clarify that i was not
retained by mr depp i was retained by mr
depp's counsel
and what i can say that yes any examinee
in a forensic context
you would consider that they're probably
stressed
all right would you agree
that all perpetrators of ipv have anger
management issues
yes
and a large portion of ipv perpetrators
have substance abuse issues
nah
it it's one of many factors that
correlates with intimate partner
violence but
there are certainly many people who
perpetuate intimate partner violence who
do not have substance abuse issues let's
go to 131
line 17.
131 you said
yes combined 12 is what i have here
and i'm talking about you said
and just to give context remember i was
asking you how many what percentage of
uh people you treat that are
perpetrators and you'd said five percent
do you recall that just for substance
i see that here okay and then i then i
said um
of the five percent that are ipv
perpetrators that you've treated over
the last eight years how many of these
perpetrators have substance abuse issues
and your answer was
i see that i answered with a figure of
speech a large portion okay thank you
and it's common for the perpetrator to
essentially gaslight the victim accuse
them of being the perpetrator
you're in a different area or are you
asking me i'm asking you a question
oh
and it's kind of sorry can you please
repeat it yes and it's common for the
perpetrator to essentially gaslight the
victim accuse them of being the
perpetrator would you agree
that's exactly how it was asked on the
deposition so i understand it is a
compound question okay objection it's
common for the perpetrator to
essentially gaslight i don't think
that's
your honor it's just i think it's just
one question
um let me try it to gaslight the victim
isn't it
that's a characteristic of psychological
abuse yes okay and and it's common then
for them to accuse them of being the
perpetrator the victim that's a
characteristic of abuse from women
perpetrated against men it's actually
very very common about 90 percent of
male victims of ipv have reported that a
female partner who abuses them
makes threats to
report their partner as an abuser it's
less common for men to make that
statement to female partners just
because there's less potential
consequence
isn't it true though that
some form of gaslighting is often
present in these personality-based ipv
scenarios
yes okay
and it's distressing for the victim to
be accused is it not absolutely it
causes them a lot of fear
certainly
and it causes them a lot of distress
absolutely yes and in fact they feel
falsely accused
correct
yes and they feel paranoid
yes and they feel frightened yes afraid
that everyone's going to believe the
perpetrator correct yes and in fact
they're afraid they're going to lose
their security correct
can you clarify what you mean by
security i'll ask the next one and
they're afraid they're going to lose
their reputation yes
okay
now let's talk about the testing for a
moment
you
talked about the mmpi 2
but that's not the most recent mmpi is
it
no it's the most researched okay
now
you
you need to have an elevated
on the mmpi there was only one section
that had elevated
elevated scores correct
no that's not correct it was the k
section correct
that's not correct okay
and
was there any elevated score over 65 on
the mmpi
i would need to take a look at it if you
know i provided a 25-page interpretation
outline if you're able to pull that up
i'd be happy to go over any of the
individual scores for you can you recall
any
clinical scales for the mmp
pi 2
for amber heard
that we're above 65 as you sit there
today again there are multiple multiple
scales on this test 25 pages worth
listed so if you can pull it up then i
can review and give you a confident
answer
what can you recall as you sit there
i i'm hesitant to do that because i
don't want to make an error by ignoring
hundreds of scale scores and would you
agree that you can't make a pathological
determination or diagnosis if the scales
are not elevated on the mmpi too i would
not agree with that okay
now one of the answers that amber gave
is that it's hard for her to feel safe
correct
what are we are you talking about the
mmpi too
again i don't recall there are 567 items
on that i would need to see her results
well it's a common trauma symptom isn't
it to not feel safe sure
and safety concerns are common among
women who have been victimized correct
women and men yes okay and common
especially for sexually victimized
people would you agree any any type of
victimization yes okay and hard to trust
that's a common after effect of
interpersonal violence related trauma
correct sure
and memory diff difficulties amber said
she felt she had holes
do you recall that
i do and her account was different than
typical memory difficulties with trauma
it is common for individuals who have
experienced and it's actually not common
no it's a symptom but it's the least
common
in fact a dsm 5 diagnosis for ptsd
includes a quote inability to remember
an important aspect of the traumatic
event end of quote am i correct yes okay
and memory difficulties are a symptom of
ptsd correct
certain types of memory difficulties yes
okay
now do you recall when amber says the
first incident of abuse took place
i believe it was oh
the first incident in which she
yes so she stated that it was early on
in their relationship okay do you recall
it i don't recall the exact date off the
top of my head do you recall it being a
tattoo something related to a tattoo i
do okay
now if someone had been subjected to a
four-year relationship characterized by
repeated ipv
they can have symptoms correct
yes
intense anxiety
yes certainly depressed or irritable
states
actually this it's not so much states
when you're looking at a real trauma
reaction it's pretty uh persistent it's
less of these transient states intimate
problems
yes relationship difficulties
yes
and these are symptoms you're also
attributing to the personality disorder
correct yes there are some key
differences okay
now let's talk for a moment specifically
about a couple of the
profiles on the mmpi
this is not an exaggerated profile for
her is it
no actually that was something unique
when she completed objective broadband
measures where the questions you don't
know what the questions are getting at
they seem completely random
she
raised scores that indicated that she
was trying to minimize any mental issues
and and appear completely free of
pathology when she took tests that asked
questions that were specific to trauma
that's when you'd see these extreme
exaggerations all right let's go to page
337.
my question on line seven this is not an
exaggerated profile is it for her
and your answer under oath at that time
was no it is not an exaggerated profile
do you see that yes we're talking about
the msi here you testified under oath at
that time correct yes that's correct now
the profile is also not consistent with
malingering correct
the mmpi 2 profile it's specific to how
she approached this test and you're
correct for this test it was a defensive
profile not an exaggerated profile
so my question on line 10 was this is
not a profile consistent with lingering
correct and your answer under oath at
that time was correct on this test it is
not consistent with millennia period
right
yes that was your full answer
okay
now is it your testimony under oath
today that you have not been asked
to testify concerning ms herd's behavior
in the context of her relationship with
mr depp
including any abuse
that's correct okay
and you have not made any determinations
including any
of opinions that ms ms heard abused mr
depp or mr depp abused ms heard correct
correct that's outside of the scope of
psychology okay and you cannot testify
whether amber heard suffered any
emotional distress as a result of any of
the defamatory comments that she has
alleged mr waldman made through mr mr
depp made through mr waldman correct
what i can testify is that there was no
indication of a decline in psychological
functioning showing any injury since
she's been with mr deb
you you cannot testify one way or the
other on that correct
your honor anime we approach
okay
dr curry
yes in your report
nowhere in your report did you
provide any opinion
of whether ms heard suffered emotional
distress as a result of the defamatory
statements is that correct that's
correct okay thank you i have no further
questions all right redirect
dr kur you were just asked a question
about
malingering yes
and made reference to the mmpi 2.
is there another test that you did to
make a determination with respect to
malingering yes so i also
well malingering is a term that
most psychologists we try to be careful
of it because it indicates an intent for
secondary gain i prefer feigning which
you had brought up earlier because it
indicates that somebody is intentionally
exaggerating but i don't know
necessarily why
so i think that's a more accurate term
in general
on the mmpi too yes there was no
exaggerated profile i also gave her the
the caps five i don't know if you'll
remember but that is the
clinician-administered ptsd scale
consistent with the dsm-5 and on that
there were signs of gross exaggeration
i also
looked at the test results that were
provided by dr hughes
and on an objective test of trauma
there is a scale specific to intentional
exaggeration on that test and ms heard
was in the 98th pro 98 percentile
meaning that she is
uh
she indic
she had engaged in extreme levels of
exaggeration
thank you uh you were asked about
uh intimacy problems relationship
difficulties associated
with ipv and and you
then said that there were some key
differences yes what are those
so
what you see when we're talking about
the personality disorders is there is a
very consistent pattern of the
aggression the violence the irritability
first of all it's escalated but second
of all it occurs when there is either
for the borderline component a threat of
abandonment a perceived slight feeling
like the person is about to leave you
about to walk away to get some space
from an argument
it's all it also occurs to a lot more
mild extent but when there's a loss of
attention and a need to manipulate to
try to get that attention back but it's
not when somebody has ptsd that
irritability is sort of at a low
constant level or it's completely random
for instance you might have a vietnam
vet who went straight to bars for a
period to get into fights with the hope
that he would kill somebody and just
self-destruct so it's a very different
type of presentation ipv it might be
more irritability but that's actually
less of a symptom for female ipv victims
usually what you'll see is somatic
symptoms the depression a lot of
fearfulness and anxiety but typically
more complaints about somatic symptoms
okay
you testified that
some
of the professionals involved in this
case had to take their patient at her
word what did you mean by that so when
you're providing therapy you're in a
very different role than an examiner
when you're the forensic examiner you're
just really looking at data to make a
decision when you're a therapist you're
an advocate for your client's well-being
and in fact it's considered extremely
unethical for a treating provider to
ever provide
opinion testimony like i'm providing
because it's so well known in our field
that you're going to have an automatic
bias for your client it's almost a
sense of protection advocacy wanting
their best which is why we also know
that it's very inappropriate to
convey any sort of opinion about whether
a crime occurred whether abuse occurred
we can certainly believe our clients we
can support them in their therapy and
take them at their word but when giving
opinions and consultations we have to be
very very cautious and really only
provide the the facts we would state
things in terms of my client did report
this
i saw this here was our treatment plan
here was the diagnosis it's uh
we just we're taught we're trained to
stay away from making any sort of
opinions understanding that most of the
time and most of ms heard's providers
were just treating ms hurd they had
never so much has done an uh initial eva
or initial interview with mr depp and
gotten his whole life story or his
symptoms or his side of any of it um and
they're going to be advocating and and
the treatment relationship is about
helping your client achieve well-being
not making uh formal psychological or
psychiatric opinions so you asked a
question about a series of doctors
dr cohen treating physician
yes he was a psychologist yeah dr banks
training physician dr banks yes treating
psychiatrist
dr anderson
yes uh treating psychologists every one
of them had to take amber where did
ander hurt his word right yes
overruled
thank you no further questions all right
is this witness subject
yes sorry
uh is this witness subject to recall
all right since you're subject to recall
dr curry please do not uh discuss your
testimony with anybody and please do not
watch anything of this card okay all
right thank you thank you you can stay
there for a moment okay all right ladies
jim we'll go ahead and take our
afternoon recess for 15 minutes do not
do any outside research and don't talk
to anybody okay
all right
let's go ahead and take our recess until
320 your next witness is by deposition
is that correct we will get you all set
up then
all right thank you
oh okay we'll come back at 3 20 before
the jury comes back out we'll discuss
your exhibits okay all right thank you
sure are they agreed on
all right ready for the jury then yes
sir okay all right thank you
uh
all right thank you your next witness
uh we call officer melissa signs by
deposition designation
and just so the jury is aware uh for the
first hour so what you'll hear is
questioning by miss herd's counsel uh it
will then shift to questioning by mr
depp's council right thank you
please state your name and your business
address
yes um officer melissa science
1546 west martin luther king junior
boulevard los angeles california
and what is your occupation
i am a police officer
okay and how long have you been a police
officer
uh going on 12 years
when
what year did you begin
as a police officer
2009
and was that with the lapd
yes it was
did you have any law enforcement
experience prior to coming to the lapd
in july of 2009
no i did not
as of may 21 2016 what was your rank
can you repeat the date
may 21st 2016.
i was a training officer
and was that a p3
correct
and as a training officer were you
considered a field training officer
right
and for how long a period of time had
you been a training officer
as of may 21 2016
approximately
i believe four months
and
who was the first officer you trained
once you became a training officer at
the lapd
i don't recall
when did you start training officer
hadden
i i don't recall the exact month
do you have an approximate
uh if the incident was in may that it's
going to be within
two months of may before or after
so are you suggesting that you may not
have started training officer hadden
until two months after the may 21 2016
incident so he wasn't there
no i'm not
was it two months or less from the time
you started training officer hadden
before the may 21 2016 incident
yes so
i have a probationer for two months
so may could have been the second month
i had him or the first month i had him
but you don't recall as you sit here
today how long you had been training
officer hadden as of the may
21st 2016 incident
correct
what does central division include
encompass downtown los angeles
in may of 2016
what shift were you on
i was working nights
and and what would the night shift
entail what was the time from when to
win
it is approximately
6 45 p.m
to 6 45 a.m
and how many days a week would you work
the shift
usually three days a week
typically what was the range of the
number of units that were working on
your shift in may 2016 in central
division
all right i don't recall
i i mean are we talking less than five
more than 10 more than 25
there would be at least five units
how high over that i i wouldn't know
that every again every night is
different the city pulls from different
divisions if there's special events
going on so it's constantly changing
[Music]
okay
but
it's usually at least five and maybe
somewhere between five and ten if
there's not a special event would that
be a fair estimate
correct
what was the process for checking out
equipment in may
2016
after roll call
we would walk to the window and
give them our name and serial number and
they would present us with
equipment for the shift
and what equipment were you given
in may 2016
after roll call
i don't
recall you don't recall any of the
equipment you were you checked out in
may of 2016 after roll call
i don't remember that specific
day that i checked out equipment i can
tell you what i typically check out if
that's what you'd like
all right let's start there
i usually check out a police vehicle
a taser
a less lethal beanbag shotgun
and a regular shotgun
anything else
no nothing else
do you check out body worn video
equipment
yes if you were trained
in body worn video then yes you would
check that out
all right were you trained in body worn
video equipment
i was not
have you ever been assigned
body worn video equipment
yes i have
when
i don't remember the specific date
what is your best estimate
if i had to guess it would probably be
june of 2016.
why do you think it was june of 2016
that you
first were assigned body worn video
equipment
because that's
the time frame that i remember
having to use it it was new to me i
never used body one before
when did the lapd start issuing
body-worn equipment for central division
i don't know that day
when approximately
i don't know i couldn't give you a date
can you name any other officer that did
not have body worn equipment that was on
your shift at any time
between november 2015 and june 2016
other than you
i cannot
have you had more than one
body-worn video equipment
body-worn camera is that what you're
asking yes
i have had
two one in central division
and now a new one at southwest division
where it currently am the camera stays
at their respective divisions
while you were at central division did
you ever get assigned more than one body
worn video camera
not to my knowledge
so to the best of your knowledge you had
the same body worn video camera
throughout the time that you were at
central division is that correct
correct
do you have a recollection of at any
time while you were at central division
your body worn video camera
not working
so you couldn't turn it on during an
incident
i do not recall that
what tools were available to you in may
of 2016 for investigating calls
answering and investigating
can you specify what you mean by tools
well
did you have a notebook for example
yes we carry field officers notebooks
and
did you have your own field officer
notebook
yes can you describe what your field
officer notebook looked like in may of
2016.
it's a small
just paper pad that we keep in our
pockets to write on
and and do you carry a pencil or a pen
with it so that you can take them out
during a call and take notes
i do
what do you do with your notebooks once
you have filled them
you can turn them into the kit room and
they can store them
is that what you have done
i have
i have my same officers filled uh field
officers notebook in my locker
uh no i thought i've had several
different ones but i usually keep them
in my locker
so
[Music]
for the field officers notebook that you
had in may of 2016
that would be in your lacquer
it should be yes
how many field officer notebooks have
you filled since you've been a police
officer
not many probably less than
less than five
and do you recall how many roughly how
many pages are in each field officer
notebook
i
no i don't recall
did you have access to dart
i don't i don't recall what hours they
worked at central division
and what did dart stand for
i don't know the specific acronym but i
know it's the domestic violence uh car
did you also have access to
report types of reports incident reports
various forms diagrams things of that
nature in case you needed them
yes they did
and where were where were those kept
while you were on a shift
i'm talking about may 2016
i usually keep uh extra spare reports in
my bag and i also keep them in my vest
so when you answered calls in may of
2016
you had reports material in your vest
as you answered calls is that correct
yes
it's a deposition exhibit number 14.
it's a multiple multiple-page document
i'm just asking if she recognizes this
document
yes i do
okay
when is the last time you reviewed this
document
about a week ago
all right
and what were the circumstances under
which you reviewed this document a week
ago
for this testimony
no i asked you some questions about uh
the
body worn video
are you aware
of anyone
any other officer being assigned your
body worn
video under your serial number
i'm not aware
is there any chance that you could be
mistaken about when you were assigned
body worn video
no there's not
and why do you say that
because everything is recorded and
documented on evidence.com under my
serial number
so if a supervisor wanted to
enter the database under my serial
number
they could watch my videos and see
the specific date and time
my videos started to record
and when the date of my last video was
to this date
all right and did you go back and look
to see what date you started
i did
what was the date that you were assigned
body worn video
equipment in central division vision
so the first day that i took out body
worn video
was june 16th of 2016.
i'm going to show you this second page
of what has been marked as deposition
exhibit number one it has you summoned
to attend and give testimony at a
deposition and also to produce
certain documents do you recall this
being issued
yes i do
and here we go
the documents to be produced
um
the first of those was
all video footage recorded by you
relating to any incident at 849 south
broadway los angeles california 90014
on may 21 2016
including all video footage relating to
incident number and it has the number on
may 21 2016.
did you conduct any type of search or or
any kind of uh
effort to see if you had any video
footage on may 21 2016 relating to this
incident the answer is no
i'm going to ask you to take did
anyone at the lapd at any point
supervisors watch commanders commanders
anyone connected with the lapd
ever asked you
whether you had any video footage
from the incident of may 21 2016. no
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
number two here it says all documents
and or communications including without
limitation any notes memoranda reports
filings and or summaries relating to any
incident at 849 south broadway los
angeles california 9001 4 on may 21
2016.
are you aware
of any documents or communications
that would fit this description
no
now
officer signs you've had training
uh on domestic violence correct
correct
could you tell me what that consists of
we received training in the police
academy
[Music]
anywhere else did you have any other
type of domestic violence training other
than when you were in the police academy
other than my experience in the field
with domestic violence no not that i can
recall
and
as of may of 2016
would you agree
that you had
answered
over 100 domestic violence calls
about yeah we yeah i go to yes i go to a
lot of domestic violence called every
day okay
and you consider yourself to be a
specialist in domestic violence is that
accurate
i don't i don't understand the title
specialist i don't
consider myself specialist
in may of 2016
what was the police officer supposed to
do when the victim of a domestic
violence would not respond to questions
or cooperate with pursuing charges after
a call was placed and the police
officers had arrived
if an individual is uncooperative
we are to check the location to make
sure that the suspect isn't hiding
for the safety of the
potential
victim and offer a business card if they
decide to speak to us later in may of
2016 was it your understanding that if
you saw evidence of injury
or property damage and disarray that you
were to file a report even if the victim
was not cooperating
correct
pretty sure he was remarked as exhibit
number eight uh and this is uh
something that is dated november
24 2018 it's to all department personnel
from the chief of police
domestic violence supplemental report
form
and it starts out with a domestic
violence supplement report form and it
has the number of it has been revised to
provide a more concise picture of the
history and needs of the victim for the
purpose of investigating the crime of
domestic violence
was this a document that you would call
receiving at some point
yes
okay and do you understand why do you
have any understanding of why
this was supplemented in november 24
2014
i do know
i'm going to ask you officer take a look
at what has been marked as exhibit
number nine
and it's called los angeles police
department domestic violence
supplemental report do you recognize
this document
yes
okay and
what is your understanding what this
document is
it's a supplemental document that we
add to a police report for domestic
violence
all right
and is this one of the reports that you
would carry in your vest
when you answered calls
yes
i'm going to ask you to take a look uh
if you if you can at the very left hand
column
where it has a number of different
uh categories here that has victim
shaking unresponsive crying scared angry
fearful
being of why
these are included on this supplemental
domestic violence report
so i identified somebody's emotional
state during an investigation
and this is specifically with respect to
domestic violence correct
correct okay and then if you can turn
over to the crime scene section on the
right hand side
you'll notice that
there are some categories that include
location vandalized
ransacked
personal property damage furniture
disarray broken
what is your understanding of why those
categories are included in there for
[Music]
making notations for domestic violence
supplemental report
to identify the crime scene at the time
of the incident
okay
and was it your understanding that these
items that they have on here may be
significant
in assisting in determining whether
there was in fact domestic violence and
improving and improving the case
and direct your attention specifically
to the evidence section
and it indicates
witnesses present during domestic
violence
statements taken evidence collected
photos taken
on there what is your understanding of
the significance of this and from
collecting this information
it's significant to tell a story about
what happened at the
domestic violence incident
okay
and then if we can scroll down a little
bit further to additional questions
there's a series of those
including
has suspect threatened to kill you
do they possess firearms have they ever
attempted to smother strangle or
suffocate you
and things of that nature what is your
understanding of why you're supposed to
ask those questions
give you a background on the
relationship an idea of what
the victim and the suspect have been
through
okay thank you just just let me ask you
the question officer science you did not
fill out
that supplemental report
when you responded on may 16 20 20
21
2016
to the broadway uh call correct with
ever heard
correct it did not meet
criteria and the question i asked was
did you fill out one of those forms
no i didn't know i did not remember here
science i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as exhibit
number 10 and if i can direct your
attention to the top
it says domestic violence standards of
review and it has field notebook divider
domestic violence laws lapd form number
[Music]
18.30.02 are you familiar with that
yes
it's it has case preparation it says
note the complainant's emotional and
physical condition do you see that
yes i do
and then ensure all evidence is gathered
and preserved eg bloody clothing damaged
phones property
you see that
yes
and it also says ensure photographs are
taken of injuries or
lack of injury
to complainant and accused
and then suggest both the day or two
after what is your understanding of the
reasons for collecting this evidence
because these are fruits of a crime
i'm sorry i didn't because these are
first of a crime if there's a crime this
is important to prove that a crime was
committed
and what do you mean by fruits of a
crime
if we're talking domestic violence
the location would be evident so if
there's
you know a house is a rants act and that
should be noted in the report that would
be considered evidence
all right then we're going to go to the
second page here
and it has
ensure photographs are taken of seen and
damaged property e.g broken furniture
holes in wall damaged
phones
phone card evidence of alcohol
consumption general disarray do you see
that
yes i did and what is your understanding
of why that would be important
same thing first of all crime
okay and then it also says canvas
location and interview all witnesses
uh including children fresh complaint
witnesses neighbors and local law
enforcement
do you see that
yes
and what would be the reason for
canvassing the location and interviewing
all witnesses
that would be further evidence
all right and what is your understanding
of what fresh fresh complaint means
i wouldn't i couldn't tell you
okay
and then if we go down a little bit
further it also has complainant
questions
and it has
questions such as length and nature of
relationship but also prior incidents of
domestic violence reported and
unreported
uh and what form of violence or abuse
has taken do you see that
yes they do
and how
what is your understanding of why that
would be important
because it gives us an idea on
background of the relationship
okay
and then we go to the next
page
and we have a little bit more here
uh we have the
too far
and that says how long the abuse has
been occurring any logs or diaries
is there a pattern of alcohol or
substance abuse what is your
understanding of why those would be
relevant
again because it gives us background on
what we're dealing with what type of
relationship this is
a and may help with the proof of the uh
the crime
right
okay and then we have identify the
person who first saw the complaint after
the incident and it says in parentheses
fresh complaint witness so i'm kind of
guessing that must be the definition
um but why would it be important to
interview or identify the person who
first saw the complaint after the
incident
they probably have the best recollection
okay and also has identified the person
with whom the complainant first spoke
about the incident fresh complaint
witness what is your understanding why
that would be important
same thing the best recollection okay
and then we have
what have neighbors seen or heard
why would that be important
they would prove to us that there was an
incident if there was other people with
the same story as a victim
okay
and then we also
have did witness observe how physical
injury occurred why would that be
important
because that would tell us that
there was a crime that somebody got
injured
and then we have
statements by the complainant and or
accused after the incident why would
that be important
because we're getting our story from the
complaint so
what they say is everything with the
crime all right let's look at 12 for a
moment this is uh
this is exhibit number 12. it's office
of the chief of police april 9 2002
and it's a domestic violence victims
memo
and it says purpose the department is
legislatively mandated to provide
specific information to victims of
domestic violence crimes
and then they go in to describe that
um
what is your understanding of
well let me go a little bit further
because i'm not trying to i'm just going
to try to move through this a little bit
quicker so it says to mitigate this
issue the department has
begun to use the victim information
notification every day vine
pamphlet
to accomplish not only the domestic
violence information required
requirements under section 13 701 of the
california penal code but also to
provide information regarding the vine
program
did you did you have a copy of that
pamphlet was that something that was
given to you
yes
okay
and was that something that you
typically provided then as it says you
should to victims of domestic violence
yes
what is your understanding of why you
were to provide the pamphlet oh okay you
understand the question
yes because it it gives resources to the
victims domestic violence resources like
uh shelters and
phone numbers to provide help i'm going
to show you what has been marked as
exhibit number 11. do you recognize this
document
yes i do this is the vine
okay would you say vine is this the
pamphlet that would be referred to okay
and it's your understanding that you
were supposed to be giving that pamphlet
to victims of domestic violence on calls
is that correct
correct
did you provide a copy of this pamphlet
to amber heard
i did not i did not identify her as a
victim of domestic violence
is that the sole reason why you did not
give that to amber
yes we want to give them to victims of
domestic violence i'm going to ask you
to take a look
at your honor
at this point your honor uh ms hurd's
counsel is asking to move into evidence
and publish to the jury defendants
exhibit 730 and mr depp has no objection
7 30 in evidence
that's it
okay
okay keep going
first page of exhibit number three it's
an incident recall
uh from
specifically may 21st 2016.
do you recognize this document
yes i do
and what please explain to me what what
it is
it's a summary of our radio call
all right and
how is this recorded
by dispatch
and
how is it communicated to you
a computer in our card
okay
so i'm going to ask you to take a look
at the very beginning of this and start
well it starts out it obviously has an
incident number
uh is this your understanding of the
incident recall
for the report to 849 south broadway
involving amber heard
yes
it starts out with 5 21
16 at 20 30 58 which is 8 30 58 or
almost 8 31
and it says incident initiated by such
and such
uh do you see that yes i do
okay and the next thing that's
communicated is penthouse 3 pr received
call from victim's friend amber
assaulted by boyfriend pr refused to
give further you see that
yes i am
now
when you were out on the road did you
see that right away or did you have to
look this up later when it was you that
was going to respond
we review the calls as we're driving to
the to the call
okay
then we have
at 5 21
20 37 which is 8 37 a duplicate call do
you see that
i do
all right let's go down to 521-16
officer science can you go where i just
highlighted here
and it's it's uh
2057
which would be what time
8.57
all right and it has s-t-a-t calling a-s
what does that mean
[Music]
so
would that be
when you and officer hadn't arrived at
849 south broadway
correct
and then it has the next entry is 521
2016. it has
21
22 57 so that would be 9 22.
okay and it says
go ahead i'll have you read this what
does it say after that
matt
with vic
check
lock verified husband left slope
vic advise
verbal okay go ahead into the next go
ahead and go into the next page or next
line go ahead
dispute and refuse to give any further
info
issued
business card
who wrote
those two lines
i i don't recall
and
what did that mean to you
those two lines that you just read
it's a it's a disposition of what
happened at the call
okay can you can you tell me what that
means i mean just tell me in real
person's words what those words are
yeah that we met with the victim
we checked the location
uh
the husband wasn't there
and that the victim advised us that she
just had an argument and that
she wasn't going to give us any further
information
and because we didn't identify a crime
we issued her a business card
letting him know that she could reach
out to us later she changed her mind and
wanted to cooperate
okay
and at what point did you close this
incident
uh whatever it says on the screen uh
let's see
9 22 57
okay and what did incident closed mean
that we cleared from the location we're
complete
done
okay
now if we could go to page
bait stamp number 12.
and do you recognize this document
i do it's a summary of all of our calls
from that day
all right and i believe you testified
earlier that you reviewed this document
in preparation for this deposition is
that correct yes i did great
okay
and if we can go down to
right here
that's
922 correct at the end of that
all right
and it says
242d domestic violence what is that
it's uh it's a code for domestic
violence
and what does the 242-d mean
that's battery officer science when we
broke before the lunch break i had just
asked you about whether
you had believed that you were at
the penthouse on may 21st 2016
uh for 30 to 60 minutes do you recall me
asking that yes i do
and do you recall testifying that that's
what you thought was the time that you
an officer hadn't spent at the penthouse
on may 21st 2016. yes i recall
okay
and in fact
it was significantly less correct
correct
okay and in fact
it was
uh you entered
from the elevator at 904 pm and went
back into the elevator at 9 19 for a
total of 15 total minutes correct
okay and and
we've seen the video clips of you
getting on the elevator and getting off
um and that's where those time stamps
come from now once you got off the
elevator at 904 pm
uh the first thing you did was listen
for some noise correct
correct
all right and then you
went around
and checked out the outdoor courtyard to
see if anyone was outside do you recall
that yes i do
and you
saw that there was a woman in the gym
who was not related to the incident do
you recall that correct
how did you know the woman was not
related to the incident
because she seemed unfazed she was just
working out
did you speak with her no i didn't do
you recall what she looked like
i don't
now
did you take any notes during the entire
15 minutes from when you got off the
elevator till when you got back on the
elevator
i did not
did officer head into your knowledge
not to my knowledge no okay did you uh
take pictures or record anything
i did not
so after you saw the woman in the gym
and and looked at the parameter you went
back to the hall the hallway and you met
with
what you called a white male who was
generic do you recall using that term
they asked me to describe him yes
and and you said generic correct
and what do you mean by generic
it didn't have any
identifying
uh i don't know nothing that i could
remember he just i just remember uh a
male white
nothing out of the ordinary
what color was his hair
i
don't even remember now did he have
facial hair a beard or a mustache
i don't remember
do you recall how tall he was roughly
i don't remember anything about him
did you ask him his name
i don't recall
now the generic white male talked with
you do you recall that yes i do
and when you first saw amber heard she
was crying red eyed and was not making
eye contact with you correct correct
and you asked her a few questions and it
was quite clear that she did not want to
speak to the police is that correct
correct
now amber heard was visibly upset so she
would look down sometimes she would look
up at you when she spoke but was back
and forth correct
what was ever heard wearing that night
i don't recall
well
hairstyle did amber heard have that
night
i don't recall
now
when was the first time you were asked
to provide details of the events of may
21 2016.
i don't recall
do you recall providing your testimony
at a deposition
in
july of 2016.
is that the first time you were asked to
provide any details of what your
recollection was of the events of may 21
2016.
all right
okay and that was roughly two months
later is that correct
correct
and how many shifts had you worked in
that two-month period
uh i'm not aware i don't know
how many calls had you answered in those
two months
i don't know that number
how many of those calls were domestic
violence calls in those two months
i don't know that number
and
if you
saw any signs of injury on amber heard
or even just damage to property
would you have been duty-bound to make a
report
correct
now
your
recollection is that there was no damage
to the the flat you searched the entire
flat and there was no damage broken
glass or anything out of the ordinary
would you agree correct
did you
see anything did you observe anything
out of the ordinary during this
particular call that you answered at the
penthouse on may 21 2016.
i did not
when you left that call when you got
back into that elevator do you recall
what you were thinking
i remember being impressed by the the
penthouse how big and beautiful it was
yes
but anything else
no nothing okay
and just so we can stay on that for a
minute you did not
you had not heard of amber heard at the
time of this report right on may 21st
2016
correct
but you didn't know that johnny depp was
an actor correct
correct
and you didn't know that that was johnny
depp's penthouse and when you reported
that correct
correct
but
you as you just said were impressed with
the penthouse would it be fair to say
you thought probably somebody
with some wealth lived there
correct can you bring up plaintiff's
exhibit number 23.
officer science do you recognize this
elevator at all
yes i do
what do you recall
that's the elevator from the location
okay
uh alex i'm going to ask you to go
to
21 19
and as you're moving that officer
science i'm going to ask you to take a
look at this and see if you can tell me
what you are saying to officer hadden
in this video clip
that's you is that correct
and officer hadden do you recognize
officer science
can you tell what you were saying to
officer hadden
i cannot does it look like you might
have said at the beginning that was
crazy
i can't tell what i was saying
would you agree though that you were
quite animated in your discussion with
officer hedden
no i wouldn't agree
how would you describe your demeanor
comfortably talking to my partner
all right i'm going to ask you to take a
look at plaintiff's exhibit number 17
and while alex is bringing that up
so your best recollection is that you
signed no injuries on amber heard
correct
correct
and your best recollection is you signed
noth no property damage nothing in
disarray nothing out of the ordinary
correct
correct
and if you had seen either of those you
would have had to file a report correct
correct
officer science let me ask you this
question so
we've established that you
uh got off the elevator on the
house level at 904 pm do you recall that
yes i do okay do you recognize the
person here
yes i do amber heard
okay
and do you see
any signs of injury
on amber's herd's face in this picture
i do not
is it your testimony
that you do not perceive this cheek to
be reflecting an injury on amber heard
correct
section here above the eyelid and now i
think with the uh i'm going to ask you
to take a look at that eyelid is it your
perception that that eyelid does not
reflect an injury
i'm sorry what was your answer
correct no injury
okay and then up above on the forehead
level where the redness is and it looks
like there's a couple of
bumps is it your perception that does
not reflect an injury
correct officer science i'm going to ask
you to look at what has been marked as
deposition exhibit number 18
close to the time that you alighted from
the elevator correct
please describe for me
what you see in this photograph
um
a striped carpet with discoloration on
the
right hand side of the photo and
what i perceive as i don't know if
that's a reflection
some sort of mark
now
you
believed and testified in fact that you
considered the hallways to be very well
lit that night correct
correct
did you see this
these stains
no not the numbers
right do you
do you
would you agree that there are those are
reddish stains on the right side
correct
what does it look like from your
experience
like a stain like from a like a liquid
red wine
possibly
it could be yes okay
but you don't recall seeing that in the
hallway after you got off the elevator
i do not
and you did not investigate this or take
any pictures or record anything about it
correct
correct
okay
now let's go to number 19.
do you recognize what is depicted in
exhibit number 19.
yes it's our business card
and it has 1a1 on the front of it what
is that that's our unit designation
and then it has hadden and a badge
number is that his badge number
that is his serial number okay serial
number thank you and it has your name
and is that your serial number correct
who who wrote this on the card
i don't recall
would it have been either you or officer
hadden
correct
do you recognize your handwriting
i i can't tell from this
no i think you indicated when you were
looking at the incident recall and the
cad summary
that a business card had been left do
you recall that yes i do
and why did you leave a business card
i advise uh amber heard that
she could contact us at any time if she
changed her mind and decided that she
wanted to
speak to us and cooperate
all right let's go to number 20.
do you recognize this
what's been depicted in this picture
yes i do it's the back of the business
card
all right and it says
5 21 2016
and the time is 9 16 p.m is that the
time that car and then it was written
correct
okay
and do you recognize the handwriting on
this side
that looks like my handwriting
okay
now it says radio call of dispute do you
see that
i do
um
did did why didn't you put verbal
dispute
it didn't
verbal dispute just do it's the same
it's the same thing to me
and you have refused to report on here
correct correct
could you just read this next part that
you wrote on here
sure advice can call at later time it
changes mind because she was
uncooperative and didn't want to speak
to us
okay
now
why did you say if change is mined
because i was giving her the opportunity
to have a resource if she changed her
mind
but if amber heard had no injuries and
there was no evidence of any type of
physical
property issues
disarray breakage etc
then why would it matter if she changed
her mind
it's a courtesy that i
i choose to give
people when i go to calls
now if amber heard had called you later
you had already closed this out and had
not written a report and had taken no
notes correct
correct
but
if i'm understanding your earlier
testimony that if you saw evidence of
injury
or if you saw injury of uh
evidence of property damage even if the
victim did not cooperate
you would write a report correct
correct
and we'll go to number 21. officer
science this is just a picture do you
recognize you and officer hadden here
yes i do
okay officer science
is the timestamp on here
of 9 19
p.m 49 p.m does that comport with your
recollection of when you left
i don't recall what time i left i'm just
going based on the video that is in
front of me
okay
do you have any reason to believe that's
incorrect
i don't
office science i'm going to ask you to
take a look at exhibit number 24 okay do
you recognize the person in this photo
yes amber heard
okay
do you perceive
uh there to be an injury or evidence of
injury on amber's face
in this fight
no i do not
uh
what is your
uh perception
of the redness on the cheek and the
eyelid and above the eyebrow
it's consistent
her crying she's fair skin her face is
flush i'm going to ask you to look at
what have been marked as exhibit number
25
do you recognize this is amber heard
yes i do do you see a red mark on amber
herd's cheek and above her eyelid and
above her eyebrow on this picture
her face looks flush yes redness
okay and what is your perception
of
what that is caused by
like i said earlier it's consistent with
what i've seen her crying
but you don't think it's consistent with
a cell phone being thrown at her
correct it does not look like an injury
caused by a cell phone
okay
and why not
because it's consistent with somebody
crying her face is flush this was taken
at on may 21st i'm going to ask you to
look at what has been marked as exhibit
number 26. it was to be recognized this
is imperfect
yes i do
officer science do you see
any redness on amber heard's cheek and
above her eyelid and
we'll go with those i do
and
what is your perception of what the
cause of those is those red marks
[Music]
consistent with her crying her face is
flesh
and is it fair to say that you do not
believe that this reflects an injury
correct
and
would it also be fair to say that you
would not consider it sufficient to
investigate further
whether it's an injury
there's nothing that would stop me from
investigating i would continue to ask
for questions
and it's up to the victim if they want
to cooperate
but just so that we were clear here even
if the victim doesn't cooperate if you
see signs of injury you still
and i believe you testified to this
believe yourself duty bone to write the
report correct
yes
but in your mind you don't perceive this
as to be reflective of an injury is that
correct
correct
and i'm going to ask you to take a look
at exhibit number 27. again do you
recognize this as amber heard
yes
okay and
do you see
redness on the cheek of amber heard on
this one
yes
all right and then you had testified on
a number of these other pictures and on
this one as well that this is consistent
with crying
do you see any redness on amber's other
cheek
yes i do
is it the same or or similar to the
redness on the cheek on the right cheek
based on this photo it looks
like one cheek is brighter than the
other
but you also don't see any
uh swelling with that
right i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as exhibit
number 28.
do you recognize this as amber heard
yes i
okay and do you see redness on the right
cheek and above the eye
yes i do
okay
and
is it your perception that this reflects
any type of or could reflect any type of
injury
no
why not
because my perception is it was
consistent with her crying
all right let's take this don't go to
29.
i'm going to ask you the same questions
do you recognize us as amber heard
yes
and do you see any
redness in the right cheek and above the
eyelid
yes
okay and
is it your perception that these are not
indicative of injury
yes
and and what is your
it's
reasoning
with recrying
let's take this one down let's go to
number 30.
now you testified
earlier that you
[Music]
thoroughly searched the penthouse did
you recall that testimony yes i do
okay
uh and
josh drew the gentleman that you called
the generic male
actually took you through and escorted
you through the
penthouse and the series of penthouses
correct
officer science did you or did you not
thoroughly search the penthouses on
may
21 2016.
we did search the pounds
okay and you used the term thoroughly
did you not
i don't recall
okay
do you feel like you conducted a
thorough
search of the penthouses that night yes
i did i did a sweep of the location for
the suspect
okay and when you're talking about a
sweep of the location did you go through
every room
yes every room
okay and was there anyone escorting you
through those wounds
yes the same male that
we were met with at the beginning of the
call
that you called the generic mail correct
correct
now you also testified a little earlier
that this was a very nice
series of penthouses right
yes
did you interview
the woman that was sitting with amber
heard
i attempted to there are all parties
were uncooperative
what what did you say to the woman that
was with miss hurt
i don't recall the exact words but i
introduced myself to everyone and asked
if they seen what happened or know what
happened
and they all refused to speak to me
did you ask for their names
i recall yes i did ask them names nobody
would give me
their names
no that's a little unusual isn't it
no it's not
a lot of people don't like us
well is it that they don't like you or
is it
potentially that they don't want to
with a domestic violence situation are
reluctant to press charges
every situation is different
based on my training experience where i
work it's usually that people do not
like us
do you have a a recollection of what the
woman who was with amber heard looks
like
no recollection
do you know what color hair she had
i had zero recollection
so you don't recall how old she was how
tall she was what her hairstyle was what
she was wearing anything about her
zero recollection
but somehow you're sure you tried to
interview her and she refused to answer
questions yes it's common practice i
try to interview everyone
during my investigation
so did you pull out your notebook at any
time while you were in the penthouse
i did not i had nothing to write no one
would speak to me
well how did you know that when you
started asking the questions that they
weren't going to give an answer
because they just looked at me
but wouldn't you pull out your notebook
first and then ask the questions
then write down the answers as they're
giving them to you no i don't put
anything in my hand for officer safety
issues until i'm sure that i have
something to learn
i'm sorry officer can you repeat your
answer
i don't put anything in my hands for
officer safety reasons
if i'm not sure i'm gonna write
i keep my hands free
when i ask the questions i got no
answers therefore i didn't
take out any notebooks or pens
did you have any reason to fear for your
safety at the time that you were talking
with them or heard in a woman with her
i always fear for my safety a potential
suspect could have been in the house so
yes i
my guard was not down if that's what
you're asking
what did you do first did you look at
the
throughout the house to ensure that the
person wasn't there or did you ask the
questions first and then look at the
house
i attempted to ask questions first
i can't just go into a house and start
checking it without asking questions
so what questions did you ask first
i don't recall specific questions
do you recall any of your questions
i don't
you recall any of the answers that you
were given
i don't recall no we went through the
domestic violence supplemental report
and some of the guidelines for officers
on domestic violence do you recall that
the crime scene a number of the items
reflected location ransacked location
vandalized furniture and disarray
personal property damage do you remember
those being
items as the checklist for pro for crime
scene for domestic violence
as they pretend to be domestic violence
reports yes i do
right
now
you
did you ever speak with the two officers
who answered the second call to the town
house that night
i did not
did you ever communicate in any manner
with the two officers who answered the
second call to the penthouse
i did not
did you communicate through a third
party to the second set of officers
relating to the domestic violence call
in your determination
i did not
did you know the two officers
who responded to the second poll
do you know who they are to this day
i do not
have you ever spoken to the other two
officers
about
uh about the responding to this call on
may 21 2016.
i have not
have you ever spoken with anyone else
about
your response and their response to this
call on may 21st 2016.
i have not
and just so everybody's aware up until
now you've been listening to question
from questioning from miss herds council
at this point i believe we're going to
shift over to questioning from mr dap's
council
i want you to focus on
the date of the incident that we have
been
talking about during this deposition
and that is
may 21st 2016.
i'll refer to that as the date of the
incident
do you understand what i mean when i say
due to the incident yes i do
okay
so as of the date of the incident
for how long had had you
been a training officer
since
i believe the end of november
of 2015.
so between six to eight months yes prior
to the date of the incident for how long
had you been a training officer
uh four to six months
okay
and uh as of the date of the incident
approximately how many
um
incidents of domestic violence
had you
[Music]
come across i couldn't tell you i have
i mean i believe we said hundreds
yes that's how i understood it from uh
testimony i read in previous depositions
of these
so
it's in the hundreds
yes okay
now
when you uh
and you indicated that
you proceeded to the incident um at the
eastern columbia building
due to
what you
heard from dispatch is that correct
correct
and do you recall as you sit here today
uh
what you were told from dispatch that
led you to the eastern columbia building
on the date of the incident
i don't have an independent recollection
okay
as you see here today do you recall that
it had something to do
[Music]
with a
dispute at that location
okay
and when you first
arrived at the scene of the incident
what did you first do on entering the
building
we met with a security guard in the
lobby
who
escorted us to the elevator
did you ask that security guard any
questions about
the building strike that suggest that
security guard any questions
not that i recall
did the security guard escort you up to
the penthouse
they gave us access through the elevator
i do not believe that
they came up to the penthouse with us i
believe they just access elevator
okay
and when you arrived at the penthouse
and exited the elevator was it just you
and your partner mr haddon
officer hadn't
yes
and what did you do next
we tried to listen for
any kind of sounds
of domestic violence
we
checked the hallways we didn't observe
anyone
we went out to a courtyard didn't
observe anyone
and
based on what i was just reminded of
there was a woman in the gym who didn't
seem involved
was working out looked fine nothing out
of the ordinary
and then we responded
to a door in the hallway and
i knocked and was met by a male
okay
up until that point of time from exiting
the elevator to knocking on that door
did you see anything that indicated
a crime i did not
open to the point where you knocked on
that door
um
did you see or hear or witness anything
indicating that there had been a
domestic violence perpetrated i did not
up until you knocked on that door did
you see anything
uh which you would have considered out
of the ordinary
i did not
and i guess what i'm asking is
walking from
the
elevator
to the gym
and then to
the door that you knocked on
was that
yes i was in the hallway
okay and during that time period from
exiting the elevator through to knocking
on the door
um was there anything in the hallway
that was unusual to you not that i
observed now
did you see any uh
stains on the floor
not that i recall
did you see any vandalism in that area
no i did not
did you see
any
broken glass in that area
i did not
okay
and upon knocking on the door what
happened next
a
may i open the door
i don't remember the exact
questions and conversation we had but
i remember asking
if they called for help and
he said that
it was the neighbor
and that she was inside of his house
apartment
with
his girlfriend
and i asked him if they could step out
and he told me
to wait and he shut the door
and we
waited we waited for them to exit
i don't remember how much time passed by
and they came out and that's when we
were met
with his girlfriend and who i know now
has misheard
in the hallway and up until that point
in time
did you hear anything that led you to
believe
that a crime had been committed i did
not
up until that point in time did you see
anything that made you believe that a
crime had been committed i did not
up until that point in time did you hear
anything that made you believe that
there had been an act of domestic
violence there
i did not
open to that point in time did you see
anything that made you believe that
there had been an act of domestic
violence there
i did not
okay
so you indicated that um
after you knocked on the door
you spoke with
and
you spoke with the gentleman is that
correct
okay
and you previously testified to
someone as a generic white male is that
the same person
yes
so your previous testimonial when you
were referring to the generic white male
that's the person who who opened the
door when you first knocked on a crack
yes there was only one male at the
location besides my partner
and there's only one note exactly the
entire time you're at the location yeah
so in the hall
you've met with a generic white male
miss herd
and a generic white male often does that
right
it was just those three folks
and you were there with uh your partner
officer hadden
correct
okay
and
how in the hallway how far were you
standing from this herd
it was close probably
like
two to five feet
okay
and at that time
did you notice any injuries on this herd
i did not
okay
uh were you looking to see if she had
any injuries at that time yes i was
and
um
so you were looking to see if miss hurd
had any injuries and he determined that
she did not is that accurate correct
and was the lighting
good enough in the hallway for you to
make that determination yes the hallways
was well lit
and at the time were you wearing any
sort of corrected lenses i was not
all right
although you are not wearing corrective
lenses where you prescribed corrective
lenses at the time
no i have never worn
glasses and i'm not prescribed i have
good vision
okay and at that time did you have good
vision
yes at the time you were observing this
herd
did you have good vision
yes i did
and did you observe any injuries at that
time i did not
what did you
ask and just heard at that time if
anything
i don't
have a independent recollection again
it's been so long i
i don't remember specific questions
okay
now let me just back up a little bit um
during the time period when you left the
elevator
and uh when ms heard came onto the
hallway
at any time did the generic white
male
tell you that there had been an act of
domestic violence no he did not
didn't tell you anything that made you
think there may have may have been an
act of domestic
violence no he did not
did he tell you anything that made you
believe that
a crime may have been committed no he
did not
and during that time period did you ask
him
what had happened or what was happening
yes i did ask him and
he just
refused to give me any information
okay so
fast forward to what we were talking
about with respect to
you in the hallway with the generic
white male ms heard and the generic
white male girlfriend
um
after we observed her and saw no sign of
injury what did you do next
i advised her that
we would be conducting a protective
suite
just to make sure that there was no one
else in the house
and
she agreed
if her neighbor the male
could accompany us with the protective
suite
okay
up until that point in time
did you ask and has heard what happened
yes i did
and what was her response
no response she was uncooperative and an
officer signed at that time was mr
cooperative
misheard was uncooperative
thank you
um and by uncooperative does that mean
that when you asked her a question she
wouldn't say a word she say something
that made you think she would not
cooperating she wouldn't say anything
okay
but just to be clear you would ask
questions and she wouldn't say anything
and what did you do at that point
after the protective sweep
i asked her
again
if she wanted to talk to me if anything
happened
again i don't remember the specific
questions that i asked her
but i asked her questions to establish
if there was some sort of
crime
who was involved and again she wouldn't
give me any information i asked i
attempted to ask her friend
uh the other woman in the room
i even
asked
the males to wait in the hallway so he
could just be us women in there so we
could talk privately
maybe she felt more comfortable that way
still to deny that there was any crime
they wouldn't answer
any specific
questions
so i wrote a business card i advised her
she changed her mind that she could call
us at any time and we would respond to
help her out
so backing up a bit to
a time here in the hallway with the
three of them
and you testified that
this herd was uncooperative
um and then
you indicated you did
a sweep
i want to start with from the point of
time in the hallway where she was
uncooperative
transitioning to the sweep
how did that occur did you
ask her if you could look at in the
penthouses how did this how did you go
from standing in the hallway to
conducting a week
i
i don't recall
you know before you
before you swept the
penthouses
did you ask if you could enter the
penthouse
yes i did
okay and who
was the response
i
i can't remember if she gave me a
response or nodded her ahead i i can't
remember
what you observed or heard from this
heard
you took it that she was permitting you
to enter the penthouses and look around
is that accurate
correct
okay
was it more than one penthouse
there was yes there was two
okay
and this turned sweep we've been using
is that a technical police officer term
what do you mean by conducting a sleep
it's called a protective sweep and we do
so to make sure that
there's some other individuals that may
be
victims that are hurt inside of the
location
or suspects
hiding concealing themselves some
officers
uh that would attack the victim after we
left the location so we go in to verify
that any potential suspects
are gone from the location for the
victim safety
thank you and you conducted a protective
sweep of two penthouses correct
correct what was your understanding of
who owned or lived in the first
penthouse that you performed a
protective sweep on
it was my understanding that
amber heard
that it was her home
again the
the gentleman
directed us that's why he came with us
so we wouldn't get lost
i see
and during your protective sweep during
the first time of the first penthouse
um
did anybody accompany you during the
entire sleep
yes the male the only male that was
there besides my partner
okay and your partner conducted this
week with you
correct
okay
and
as to the protective sweep of the first
penthouse
did you
go into every room of the penthouse
to my knowledge yes
and was your knowledge based on
the generic white male leading you
around
was it your understanding
that you
did your protective sweep um included
you looking in every room in the
penthouse
all right
during the protective sweep of the first
penthouse
um
did you
see anything
that
led you to believe that a crime had been
committed
i did not
during the protective belief of the
first penthouse did you hear anything
that made you think the crime had been
committed
i did not
during the first protective sweep did
you see anything that made you think
that an act of domestic violence had
occurred
i did not
during the protective sleep of the first
penthouse did you
hear or see anything
i'm sorry did you
hear or say anything that made you
believe an act of domestic violence had
occurred
i did not
okay
upon your completion of
the sweep protective sweep of the first
penthouse
up until that point in time
um from
you exiting an elevator up until that
point in time did you hear or see
anything that made you believe that a
crime had been committed i did not
open to that point in time did you
hear or see anything that made you think
an act of domestic violence had occurred
i did not
now i want to
ask you
testified that
you testified to you
viewing
misheard
and not seeing any signs of injury
did you view her again after that
first dealing
during the interviews and throughout the
entire investigation i'm constantly
scanning her and watching so i if i see
any other observations that would
indicate any injury or domestic violence
and did you see anything like that
and you didn't see
did you see anything like that during
the entire
entire time period
you are on that call
and
do you believe that you
had enough time
viewing this herd to determine whether
or not
she had sustained any injuries
yes i do
can you determine did he determine that
she sustained any injuries
i determined that she did not sustain
any injuries
so other than the conversation you had
with her in the hallway when you first
got there did you have any other
conversations with misheard
i did
inside of the inside of the lost
or penthouse sorry
okay was that before or after the
protective sweep this week
i believe both before and after
i attempted
okay how many conversations separate
conversations did you have with mr
i don't recall
okay
there was at least the one in the
hallway
and there was one
before or after the protective suite
correct i'm sorry that's that answer
correct
okay
and
during the second conversation you had
with her after the one in the hallway
how close were you to her
the same
two to five feet she was right in front
of me
were you close enough to get a good view
to determine whether or not she had any
injuries
yes i was okay
and during that second conversation did
you determine
whether or not she had an injury
i determined that she did not have any
injuries
at any point in time during the incident
during the date of the incident
did she complain of any injury
she did not
during the protective sweep of the
penthouse
did you see anything
in disarray
i did not
okay
now you indicated let me ask you did you
do a protective sweep of the second
penthouse
yes i did
did the generic white male accompanying
you accompany you on that sweep as well
yes he did
what was your understanding of who owned
or resided in that second penthouse
i had no idea
okay
um
did you
during that second protective sweep
did you
walk through every room in that
penthouse
from my understanding yes we did
okay
and during that second protective sweep
did you see anything that you would say
was in disarray
i did not
during that second protective sweep did
you see anything
that made you believe there had been a
crime committed
i did not
during that second protective sweep did
you hear anything that made you think a
crime had been committed and then uh
during your protected sweep of the
second penthouse
did you see anything that made you
believe an act of domestic violence had
occurred i did not
during the protective sweep of the
second set
second penthouse
did you hear or say anything
that made you believe
a crime had been committed
i did
not after you've performed the second
protective i'm sorry after you performed
the protective suite sweep of the second
penthouse what did you do
i responded to where amber heard was
and i again tried to
see if i could get any information from
her
i was unsuccessful and then i issued her
the business card
and let her know that she could call us
back if she wanted to talk
did she answer any of your questions
no she did not
at any point in time during the entirety
of the incident didn't miss her answer
any of your questions
no she did not
the entire time of the incident did miss
her complain of any injury
no she did not
during the entirety of
your time at the incident
did
anybody say anything that made you
believe a crime had been committed
no they did not
during the entirety of the time you were
at the incident did anybody say anything
that made you believe an active
act of domestic violence had occurred
no they did not
during the entirety of your time at the
incident did you see anything
that made you believe a crime had
occurred
i did not
during it during the entirety of your
time at the incident did you hear
anything that made you believe a crime
had been committed
i did not
during the entirety of your time at the
incident did you hear or see anything
that made you believe an act of an act
of domestic violence had occurred i did
not
had you heard of
anybody by the name of ms hurd at that
time never
never heard
no i've never heard of amber heard
before that time okay
did you recognize any of the people that
you encountered during the incident
i did not
at the time of the incident did you have
any reason to believe
that
anybody you encountered at the incident
uh
was famous
i did not
okay
and during the entire time
you're at the penthouses
during the incident
did you have any reason to believe that
mr depp was affiliated
or involved
in the incident
i did not
i'm adam reporter can you
repeat my last question i lost where it
was
question
during the entire time you were at the
penthouses during the incident did you
witness any bruises on this herd and
there was not a response
it did not observe any injuries on this
earth
did you observe any swelling on a third
state
i did not
did you observe anything
that led you to believe
that she was a victim of domestic
violence
i did not alex if you can pull up
exhibit two
[Music]
so is this going to be exhibit 57
uh yeah
officer signs you recall having your
having your deposition taken
on july 18 2016 in connection with
mr death and miss heard
yes
okay
and
he would recall
getting testimony in connection with
that deposition
yes i'm sorry officer yes
okay
and
did you give
accurate and true testimony at that time
yes
okay
and you understood you were under all
correct
okay
alex if you can go to page 26
officer signs do you recall testifying
as to
um
people testifying that
and i'm talking about today
if you recall just testifying that
you can't recall what
this word said to you if anything i do
not have an independent recollection but
i can
go off what i'm seeing here on my screen
okay
uh your honor we're at five o'clock it
looks like we have about uh 18 minutes
left do you want to you don't have any
problem finishing it tonight dude let's
go and finish it okay thank you
and you agree with me that your memory
of the
day
of the incident
was fresher
on july 18 2016 than it is today
yes that is correct
okay and
the incident was may 21st 2016.
this deposition was taken july 18 2016.
how long after the incident was this
deposition taken
um a few months
okay
and
tell us if i could have control
[Music]
it's a little delayed out of that cannot
be fixed that just the way it
uh is is alex speaking
uh yeah i'm afraid i can't uh help that
i'm sorry mr president
that's fine
officer science i'm gonna start here do
you see my cursor
yes i
okay
do
gonna start here at line three
the question is
okay but we'll get back to that
before you did a a sweep
or a check of the rest of of the
penthouse
did you have an opportunity to speak
with miss heard when you were in the
apartment answer yes i did
okay question okay can you tell us
about
that conversation
answer sure i asked her what happened
opening question she said nothing and
she continued to cry i said
who do you live with who do you live
here with she shook her head as if she
did not want to answer
i asked her are you hurt
do you need an ambulance
and she shook her head again no
at that point i asked her if she mine if
she would mind if i checked her
apartment and that's when she said no
officer does this refresh your
recollection of the conversation you had
with ms hurd at that time yes it does
and your testimony that i just read is
that true and accurate
yes it is during the entire time period
you were at the penthouses
on may 21st 2016.
did ms heard say that she had been
assaulted in any way by anybody
no she did not
okay
okay
during
your protective sweep of the two
penthouses
did you view anything that you would
characterize as vandalism
i did not
during the entire time you were at the
penthouses on may 21st 2016.
were you looking for any probable cause
to believe
that a crime had been committed
yes it was
and what did you determine
i determined there was no crime
did you where did you determine with
respect to an assessment of probable
cause
there was no probable cause of any sort
of crime
thank you
um
uh
[Music]
during the entire time
you were at
the penthouse on may 21st 2016.
were you wearing
any body worn
video cameras i was not
are you certain of that
i am certain
and how are you how is it that you are
certain of that
because i didn't start using body worn
video until
june of 2016.
and that's after
uh the date of the incident correct
correct
alex if you would mind putting exhibit
nine back up
so
officer science you were shown this
document earlier what is that talking
about
it is a domestic violence supplemental
report
do you recall uh council asked you about
the victim column and the crime scene
column
yes i do recall
you also see that there's a suspect
column in the middle
yes
okay
and is there any difference between a
victim column and a suspect column with
respect to
the terms and the terms
the box terms
no difference
did you fill out one of these forms in
connection with your investigation on
may 21st 2016.
i did not
why not
because it was determined there was no
crime
and officer signs just one more question
with respect to that exhibit nine i know
it's not up
but
the fact that you did not fill out that
form
uh
is that
consistent with your training
yes it is i wouldn't fill that out
because
there was no crime it doesn't
it's not called for
when you testified
during the london trial
at the time did you believe your
testimony was accurate
yes i do
at all times you've testified
[Music]
under
in any legal proceedings trials
depositions
uh
do you always give accurate and truthful
testimony yes i do
and do you have any reason to not give
accurate and truthful testimony
in connection with about this deposition
i do not
officer sign do you see these two
pictures
yes i do
um do you recognize the person in the
picture
between these two pictures
yes i i do the lighting
of the photos
do you see any difference in connection
with
the redness on the cheeks of this herd
as between these two pictures
yes i do the
the left side is
the photo's brighter
okay
and other than that would you agree with
me that
these two pictures
are the same in other words
the search face
uh
the position of her face
everything about
her in these pictures is
identical except for the differences
that you've indicated
yes
okay
and even though these are the same
pictures do you see any difference with
respect to
the redness
in
on this word's face with respect to the
two patients yes the photo on the left
is brighter causing the redness on the
cheeks to
what appears to be brighter or
exaggerated
what does it say
with respect to
let's concentrate on fish on the left
can you read for me what it says in the
little box
at the very top on the left
under add a title do you see a date and
a time stamp
yes i see it
what's it say date and time stamp
date is may 21st 2016.
timestamp is 9 25 12
p.m
and now let's look at the other picture
exhibit 29 at the same spot can you read
for me that what the time stamp says
there
yes it says uh may 21st 2016 9 25 12 pm
so both
exhibits both pictures have the same
exact time stamp correct
and even though that's the case you
still believe
that there's a difference between
the two pictures as you previously
described
three signs do you see that at 41.
yes
you recall council asking a question
yes
during your
uh protective sweep of
the two penthouses on may 21st 2016
did you see anything in disarray
no
officer
signs
i think you answered this but up until
up until the president for how long have
you been a la
los angeles police officer
i will be going on 12 years
officer science uh
in connection with your investigation uh
at the
eastern columbia building on may 21st
2016.
were you
in a rush in any way
investigation
were you willing to stay as long as
necessary to determine if a crime had
been committed
yes
at any point in time
during your investigation on may 21st
2016 at the penthouses didn't miss herd
ask you to file a report
no
did anybody
uh that you spoke with or saw
on may 21st 2016
at the penthouses asked you to follow
the court no
did you have any cause
to file a report
no and was that determination in line
with your training yes
if you had witnessed anything
that led you to believe that an act of
domestic violence had occurred would you
have filed a report
yes
and you in fact did not follow the
report correct yes
and
if you had witnessed something
that led you to believe that an act of
domestic violence had occurred
would you have followed the report even
if ms hurd had asked you not to
yes
and is that is that in line with your
training
yes
officer science you were asked some
questions
and just so everybody's on the same page
we have about a minute and a half of
questions from mrs council at this point
when you
were
got off the elevator in the penthouse
and when you got on and how much time
you spent at the penthouse level i i
approached it in my earlier but based on
the cross-examination i feel like we
need to go back
to that
so i'm going to ask you to take a look
at what is exhibit number six
and you recognize
you and officer hadden in this picture
yes
okay
and what time does the timestamp on this
uh picture
say for the elevator
it says 2104 4443
okay that's 904 43 would that be right
p.m
yes
and we looked at this earlier i'm going
to ask you to take a look at it again at
21 and so this one has what time
21
1949.
all right and allowing for your and
officer science you said earlier that
you weren't sure whether there were
accuracies or inaccuracies in terms of
the elevators
but allowing for that there may be any
issues at all would you agree that it
still means that you were on and off
that elevator in 15 minutes
assuming the times are correct yes
okay you were asked uh to look at a
number of the pictures that i had shown
you earlier that were taken on the night
of may
21st 2016
both before during and after the time
that you and officer hadden had reported
to
the uh
to ms heard's uh penthouse do you recall
seeing those again and being asked about
them
yes you were asked uh by
council for mr depp to take a look at
those again correct
right
okay
and he asked you if you had seen any of
those photographs before and you
indicated that you had not correct
correct
so
other than what was placed in the cad
summary by either you or officer hadden
and then also went into the incident
recall
do you are you aware of any
documentation that either you or officer
hadden
collected
relating in any manner to your visit to
the penthouse on may 21
2016. no
all right thank you all right ladies and
gentlemen that concludes uh the
testimony for today please do not do any
outside research and don't talk to
anybody about the case and we'll see you
tomorrow morning okay thank you
all right i i still have some
outstanding exhibits so if you could get
with jamie and see who wins those are so
we can get that taken care of so we
don't get backwards and we keep keep up
all right all right we'll see you in the
morning all right thank you
foreign
that sounds like change of plan
[Music]
oh what a producer